[Music]
[Music]
the semi-final drama continues today and
for the two players who fell behind on
day one
it is all or nothing today can they
fight back
and take the matches to tie breaks well
ladies and gentlemen
we are one day away from the skilling
open final
welcome to the champions chess tour
welcome to my humble abode
this time i'll be playing from moscow
but here is where i live
hi this is there are time differences so
i have to change my sleep schedule
accordingly this is my usual work spot
power so this is my desk
we need a very good mouth there's the
old mouse i use for all the other
tournaments
it can be a little bit dark in here some
of the medals
i love online chess because i can play
from the comfort of my home
having indian food lots of lots of stuff
for winning the skilling open is not
enough i need some more
skilling open is the very first
tournament in the champions chess tour
we are done with preliminaries we're
done with quartz finals and we are done
with
day one of semi-finals today we will
find out
what two players take the tickets to the
final and to take us
through the drama that will be happening
today we do have women's grandmaster
ivanka houska and grandmaster david
howell
and david for the two players who have
to get back today
to get those wins uh i mean do you think
we will see blood on the
chessboard today i'm hoping for it kaya
i'm so excited the two players who did
lose yesterday
yana pogniacci and hikara nakamura they
are fighters they'll be throwing
everything at their opponents to try and
get back into this match
when you went in the quarter finals we
did see some great comebacks we did get
those
tie breaks who do you think has the best
chance among the two players behind
to get that tie break today well you
said it in the quarter finals we saw
something
magical three of the quarter finalists
made an amazing comeback to qualify for
the semi-finals
the players in question hikaru nakamura
in apogee can
do it and in fact twitter is behind them
we have a tweet from john brazil who
says
i'll be rooting for hikaru and ian and
promise you during today's
skilling open because morechas is better
than less chess
and that's not just me saying that it's
science
and do remember that if you do want to
join in the conversation
and the fun please tweet us using the
hashtag chesthumps
and david i guess the players behind
hikaru nakamura and janna pognachi
they need all the great energy they can
get from social media
and everywhere today because it must be
very hard and very
exhausting to have to fight back against
great chess players
no that's right remember it's four games
as well today potentially
or even more if the matches go to break
so the players they'll definitely need
that energy
don't need much more energy than
yesterday where they did struggle a bit
towards the end
i just can't wait all right well magnus
carlsen the world champion was the
favorite before the semi-final against
jana pomnyochi
and the russian he got off to a
devastating start
oh look at the bar he's just shuffled
his queen across he's defending his
knight right now
but maybe this is the move that uh
napoli actually has missed cutting the
coordination between his queen and
knight
i think he's slowly starting to realize
what he's done he's just been caught
unaware it was the worst thinkable start
to the semi-final for ian apominati
against magnus carlsen i think queen b8
is a little bit weird comparing to queen
c7 but
uh i would i would like to squeeze the
seminar board not queen b8 queen beat is
clearly losing game
because of d6 but the russian got
several chances to strike
back i'm not actually playing very
accurately so far
okay not sure about that last move um oh
the computer hates it
yeah that's the that's the thing that
one moves the difference
and when carlson ran into problems with
the internet connection
nepalniacci had great chances for a win
in game three
i think the pressure's getting to him
he's forgetting that his most important
pawn is that la pawn on the left there
now oh the computer hates that move i
think napoleon has blown it
he has blown it i would say he was the
victim of himself you know he was the
one who took the bad decisions i
kind of feel relief right now because in
the first game i returned the favor
from the group stage when magnus mixed
up the square fall for his queen
with a win in game one and draws in the
rest of the games
carlson ended up as winner of the first
semi-final match
uh it was quite similar to
the first day of the match with uh
budanish actually
nada was mainly struggling
well actually magnus carlsen here in
that interview he seemed kind of low on
energy even if he did win
uh ivanka what do you expect from the
world champion today
wow the world champion is a tough
customer he is one of the strongest
players around here is the benchmark
and i do think that this tweet by howard
staunton really sums it up
beautifully says mr carlson is a
terrible antagonist
once he has obtained a superiority of
force no matter how small the advantage
he seldom gives his opponent
a moment's rights to the game is past
all surgery
and there you go there you have it he is
magnificent and it also friana pogniacci
yesterday
it wasn't all about magnus playing good
chess also he had these small
blunders all the time that that ruined
it for him in winning positions do you
think he is able to forget about that
and
come back strong today david he needs to
forget he also needs to forget who he's
playing
yes he's playing one of the best
defensive players of all time magnus
carlsen
but i think jana pomnechi against anyone
in the world he would have backed
himself to win that game
i think on any other day he might have
won that game he just needs to forget
he'll get his chances today he just
needs to take them when they come
what do you expect from these first
games if i go knowing that yana
pomnyachi
he needs to win some games yeah
absolutely he must
win so he has to come out there swinging
fighting
doing whatever he can being the russian
bear he has to scare magnus
and magnus he is not known even if he is
in the lead he's not known for
for going for that those draws do you
think he also wants to
show off some good chess today david
definitely i mean he's perfected the art
form of winning without being at his
best
but he knows that before the finals he
needs to show the world that he is still
um kind of the king of online chess
magnus carson not at his best so far
maybe saving it for the critical moment
either way he's going to need he
need to play better than yesterday all
right well in the other semi-final
hikaru nakamura
was the big favorite against wesley so
in the all-american battle between the
two
but nakamura he got off to well not the
best start
we can see nakamura we talked about his
faces but once he starts to exhale a lot
breathe out a lot he knows it's all over
with a win in game two against hikari
nakamura wesley so got off to a great
start in the semi-finals
i feel very good today but at the same
time i think he can play some part today
i'm sure tomorrow he'll he'll play two
times harder
i'm going to have a sleep last night
nakamura was
never able to get back and with the rest
of the games ending in draws
so was the winner of day one good
feeling to
to be in the lead but every match is
different tomorrow
try to play solidly of course i mean
four draws is more than enough
start to not run into any problems with
the black pieces
especially in the opening and uh
hopefully be able to be able to hang on
i thought the final game actually
it was very close to winning for me but
unfortunately it was by one move
i can't chuck made him on the h file so
it was a little bit unfortunate but it's
it's only one
day so you know we play play again
tomorrow
well if one player will be able to get
back it is hikar nakamura he seems like
such a cool and
and confident guy yeah he is he is after
all the king of online chess
one of the best blitz players around and
i definitely think that he has to come
out there
be very aggressive wesley so is one of
the most pragmatic
players that is out there so i'm
expecting wesley to be a little bit more
defensive and just
hold the fourth down all right well we
are done with the first days of
semi-final it's
all or nothing today the decisive day of
the semifinals now let's
take a look at the standings and
after the quarter finals we did see
magnus crossing yana pomnyachi
wesley so and hikaru nakamura go through
to the semi-finals
magnus carlsen is leading by one point
against jana pognaci after the first day
and so is wesley saw 1l up against
hikaru nakamura after
day one and that means that means that
janupomnyachi and hikaru nakamura
has to win today's uh four
games match that means they need to to
beat minus carlsen and wesley so within
four games if they want to take it to
tie breaks
and hopefully they would we will have
tie breaks and
what does that mean that's right so tie
breaks the times will be slashed on the
clock
each player will just have five minutes
for each blitz game it's the best of two
blitz games
five minutes on the clock plus three
seconds after every move
um if the two blitz games if it's one
one at the end of those
we will see armageddon chess white will
have five minutes black will have four
minutes but white has to win otherwise
he will be knocked out
the time will be slashed it will be so
exciting to watch i knew that before oh
we definitely hope for tiebreaker anchor
yeah we absolutely too is the best thing
it is the best thing okay well wesley so
he is leading the match against hikaru
nakamura but he is
expecting some great chess and some
blood from hikaru nakamura today
i think he ever played sub par today uh
so i'm sure tomorrow he'll
he'll play two times harder uh so
i'm going to have a sleepless night but
yeah i'm sure he'll be back tomorrow i'm
sure he'll play much better
but today is just not his day tomorrow
try to
play solidly of course i mean four draws
is more than enough
start to not run into any problems with
the black pieces
especially in the opening and uh
hopefully be able to be able to hang on
if i played like i did today i'm pretty
confident
but uh we'll see i've had bad days and
i've had good days also
you know you just come back play and um
luckily it's the best of two and not a
best of one
i mean i just try to play play good
chess and see what happens then if i
play good chess i think there will be
opportunities um and whether i can
capitalize on them or not is really the
question but
you know we'll see well actually david
he car nakamura almost looking like a
movie star
in his in his office uh his online chess
office there and
he just seems full of confidence it i
almost feel that he's
very capable of taking back the match
today definitely
if he can do it anyone can i also want
to know what that what's in that fridge
behind me
maybe full of energy drinks um full of
magical treats to help
help give him that energy that he needs
today he's up against one of the most
solid one of the coolest customers out
there though wesley so
hicaro he knew to be at his best but
he's done it before he's come back
before
he has come back before and ivanka um
what sort of openings and what you
expect from hikari today
knowing he has to win he is going to go
for very committal
openings i think he will go aggressively
from the get-go and
i will think that wesley so in response
will perhaps
tighten himself up into a little ball
and
just defend until he's given the
opportunity to counter-attack
all right well magnus carlsen he said he
felt it was all about
surviving yesterday he definitely did
survive
now let's hear what it's all about today
for magnus carlsen
i guess i'll try to prepare better in
the in the openings
um as you could see in the first game
was well prepared and then he made a
mistake early on and i won
one quite easily um but in the others
especially in the third game i didn't
really get what i
i want so i'll have to cook up something
something new there but overall like i'm
pretty happy to have uh
have survived and uh i feel like in
these matches like if you can
survive your your worst day you're
probably going to be
be fine overall i think lasker said that
it's the most difficult
chess is to win a winning position so
that's
uh that's something i i surely need to
master before tomorrow's match
i i don't need i need some extra energy
extra motivation for
i come back anyway this is best of two
so one
one match you may lose but second you
you get away yeah so that's uh the rules
are very simple
well yeah do you believe he's capable
of striking back today david i think he
can in the past he has been
magnus carlsen's kryptonite he has
beaten magnus carson
especially in their over-the-board
encounters he just needs to transfer
that form
into online chess
semi-final day two are about to start
two of these players will be heading to
the skilling
open final starting tomorrow mayana
pomoniacci and hikaru nakamura
has to fight back if they want to take
the semifinals to tie breaks
and we're so excited the day two of
semifinals is
soon starting the first match is between
magnus carlsen
and yon pomnyacci and david there is no
doubt
jana pognati is capable of beating
magnus carlsen that's right he showed it
yesterday he's capable of
building up those winning positions he
just needs that killer instinct he needs
to finish off
uh finish off those games we see their
head-to-head scores there
as well in classical chess over the
board chess yana pop niacci is dominant
with five wins to one
but in rapid games magnus carson is the
one in the ascendancy the pontiac needs
to turn that around
and the other mats the one we will
follow the first game for is between
hikaru nakamura and wesley so and ivanka
nakamura while he is the online champion
he is the online champion and you can
actually see it there
by looking at their rapid scores wesley
though only has nine victories to hikaru
karu nakamura's 16. so definitely the
statistics are in hikari's favor
the all-american battle between wesley
and
hikaru nakamura and we see the four
players in the semi-finals
one of those players and one of the
other players will be heading to the
final
and here we are these are live um
webcams of the players now sitting
waiting and wesley so the last one to
come
in here david do you think he's ready
and happy and
and going to fight today to to get that
final
yeah wesley so he looks fresh he said he
might have a sleepless night thinking
about the results but i think that was
tongue-in-cheek he knows that today is
going to be a long
long day for him he knows he needs to be
full of energy and there we see the
moves being played
very fast on the board wesley so with
the white pieces he's pushed his king's
pawn forward
on the first turn we see a very quick
opening moves here this opening is
called the spanish
the spanish opening um it normally
signifies that wesley so as white he's
happy to be solid
and nakamura in return he's played
something i've never seen him play
before
he's just pushed a pawn there on the
right side of the board normally he
would develop his knight instead he's
played something to try and surprise his
opponent
it's something a bit rare um he's going
to try and throw wesley so
off uh off out of his comfort zone at
this early stage i like what hikaru
nakamura is doing
it shows that he's out for blood yeah
definitely
it is a very uncommon response to
develop the the pawns on that right hand
side so early on but it has been seen
before
and so far the players are all following
the theory we already we already see on
our beloved bar
it is uh slightly on white's side wesley
seoul's side
um should we pay attention to it this
early in the game
that's right kaya so the bar below the
player is the green bar um we will see
it zooming right zooming left
um throughout the game but at the moment
when it mean
when it says something like 0.7 that
means the game's roughly in the balance
it's slightly in white's favor
but it's still very early days a lot of
play
left here and we see white has had to
retreat his bishop there
white has done something that i
recommend everyone at home doing he's
castled his king which means he's pushed
his king to the right side of the board
keeping it nice and safe for later
hikaru nakamura countering in the center
we've seen a trade of pawns in the
center
this is all quite well known stuff but
maybe because it is a surprise hikaru
nakamura he studied it this morning
it might be less familiar for wesley so
all right well we can't stress enough
that it is uh
it is all in hikaru nakamura's uh
shoulders to to win today he is under
after yesterday wesley is a one day one
and hikaru nakamura he definitely needs
at least
one win today to take it to thai bricks
yes he does he
needs to win the match and there's four
games in that match we have to remember
so yeah everything to play for and
it's certainly the game is actually
still very much
mainstream it's all been played before
but uh it's kind of a little bit
off-putting how quickly
wesley is playing and how it's now
hikaru that is pausing for thought and
he's doing
david you noticed it before he's he was
looking up to the left
that's right so hikaru when he looks up
to the corner it just means he's trying
to recall what he's studied before he's
just trying to remember
it's always difficult especially as we
get a bit older in chess terms it's not
easy to remember what we've studied
we see white's last move he's moved his
rook across we can see that on the
bottom right hand corner with
the yellow squares that have been
highlighted that's the last move been
played
um white's just shifted his rook across
one square attacking the black king
rooks love these open lines black's king
is forgotten to castle is still in the
middle of the board
that king is a bit weak so black needs
to decide do i block
maybe i can block with the bishop maybe
i can block with a knight retreating
or a move that nobody likes to play do
you move the king
there's three ways to deal with the
check you have to block you have to run
away or you have to capture the
attacking piece
instead he's decided to block with his
bishop after a bit of thinking that
nakamura trying to surprise his opponent
at this early stage
but maybe he's the one who's less
familiar
it turns out wesley so looking very
confident at this early stage i like
white's position
i i certainly like white's position as
well but we have to stress though
if the black king manages the castle
which is to get into safety then black
should be standing okay
white has to run with the momentum has
to start developing the pieces
especially on the left hand side of the
board and has to start
tickling black and causing some problems
that's right ivanka mentioned it those
white pieces there at the bottom left
side
they're still at home they still haven't
moved you need to use all of your pieces
in the early stage of the game you need
to bring them towards the center
there we see white has jumped forward
with his bishop he's actually
eyeing up the black queen now with that
bishop the black queen is attacked
along that bishop's diagonal black will
move the queen now
most likely a very nice move there from
wesley so
it's worth noting as well that white's
bishop is protected
by a knight that black queen cannot
capture that bishop right now
um hikara nakamura just trying to shake
it off a bit
yeah looks like he's still trying to
warm up get in the zone
it's quite early i think in the us it's
still very early in the morning so
maybe he's just woken up not long ago
maybe he's going to take him a while to
get into this match
yeah and uh wesley is so rattling out
the move so although that this
this was a surprise from hikari
completely unexpected
it does seem like wesley knows exactly
what to do which is a little bit
off-putting
that's right and i really like what
wesley is doing if we bring up the board
we can see his threat his next move
his lot uh he's moved his knight forward
he wants to jump
further forward with his knight he wants
to jump in
one more time and attack the black queen
that night going on a bit of a journey
but if you can improve your pieces like
this if you see a very nice square for
your pieces
it's often worth investing two or three
moves uh to make that happen if wesley
gets this one move if he gets his knight
into the black position this knight it's
on a square that we call an
outpost it cannot be attacked by a black
pawn
it looks like hikaru he's actually
ignoring that potential threat he's just
moved his bishop
one more time creating a bit of an
awkward
tension along this diagonal pinning this
white knight
that a pin means that the knight cannot
move now white's knight cannot move on
this square
otherwise the white queen will be
attacked so both sides being very
aggressive at this early stage
fantastic and i really like wesley so
answered to that
he has pushed his pawn on the right hand
side
and you can see that pawn is asking a
question to the bishop what are you
going to do and i love questions like
that
that's right so black's bishop's now
attacked by a pawn the bishop has to
either run away
or jump forward and capture that white
knight
black cannot afford to give up his
bishop for a pawn that's not a good
not a good trade so hikaru nakamura does
he retreat or does he capture the white
knight
very tense moment but hikaru slightly
shaking his head
i think he's just shocked by wesley's
speed at this early stage
wesley so confident in the opening and
we and we know that
we know that hikaru nakamura is going
for wins uh in these games
can we say by the opening here if wesley
so is
actually trying to get a win here or if
it he's just playing safe for that draw
he's not playing safe for that draw
that's for sure he's just simply
developing his pieces so he has
responded in a quiet
and he's smiling wow i'm
so shocked at black's last move oh oh
and look at the bar
we see the bar jump as well um i'm not
surprised
if we bring up the board we can see that
black's just lost two moves
he's just given up um i mean he's moved
his bishop forward then he's moved it
straight back
if we join the position two moves ago
black moved his bishop whoops he
moved his bishop forward along the
diagonal to this square
wesley so attacked that bishop now he's
just gone back why did he jump forward
if he had to retreat in the first place
and we see
just above the board on the right hand
side there we see stockfish's evaluation
of the position
stockfish is the computer program it
thinks that white has three moves to
give a huge advantage
and wesley has done that wesley so has
got a very big advantage now his rook
nicely in the center of the board
nakamura he just lost two moves he just
gave wesley two moves for free
yes for sure absolutely that didn't make
any sense
whatsoever and yes oh dear
not a great start for hikaru nakamura
and
that would disappoint some of his fans
if he were to leave the competition
because we do have a tweet from lars who
says
cheers from namibia i'm rooting for
hikaru
and then he compliments us by saying
great warcraft thing to us
thank you very much yes so nice to hear
all right hashtag chess champs we
i think the players today need to get
that energy from social media so
great for a car we know he has a lot of
fans out there that's right both players
have a lot of fans this all-american
battle
we have nakamura a former u.s champion i
think five or six times he's won that
and wesley so the new us champion the
second time he's won the title
um both players i mean i'm a fan of them
both and they both have huge support
networks and i'd love to hear more from
um from those support
meanwhile the position though um wesley
so he's
we saw him smiling he knows he's in the
driver's seat oh and the glass is on
he needs business he means business but
i mean it's absolutely wonderful for for
wesley like psychologically as well that
uh after he put the question
to that bishop earlier on that hikaru
doubted himself
and retreated the bishop and just gave
him two free moves
unbelievable that's right and hikaru
we hear with the little ping that's
whenever a move is being made
hikaru he's shaking his head his last
move was to bring his
black rook towards the center um that
rook though
is very passive it is just blocked by a
pawn it's a very defensive move
nakamura he knows it's all gone wrong
wesley so has very nice control of the
center i especially like that
white rook in the middle of the board
very powerful
it's looking like wesley so all he needs
to do now is activate that rook on the
bottom left side of the board
if you can activate that last rook bring
all of his pieces towards the center
hikaru nakamura is going to be in big
big trouble
so is that what we're looking for from
wesley as he's thinking now to
to move his queen so that also that rook
can can get out of that corner
exactly that's exactly what he needs to
do he needs to involve all his pieces
into the attack and once he does that
then the plate starts to flow
very naturally and once you've
pinpointed your
weak point that you're going to really
put the pressure on
is even better and i think it will be
that porn that is all by itself
it doesn't have any pawn support in the
center
so i would be targeting there that's
right if we bring up the board i think
wesley so
okay he does push a pawn at the edge
there he pushes the ball on the h line
we call that pawn harry
harry the horn he's on a mission oh wow
i'm loving this david absolutely
fantastic because
wesley i did predict that he would play
it very safely
but he has been provoked and wesley is
now playing for an attack
he wants to soften up the protection
around the black
king and he is going for those pawns
that's right so
we see that that pawn has just moved
it's going to launch forward it's going
to be
used as a battering ram just to explode
um everything
just to break black's uh king shelter
essentially personally i was expecting
as you mentioned kaya just a
move maybe with the queen bring this
rook into the game target this weak pawn
that ivanka was mentioning earlier
but i love this move by wesley it shows
that he's not scared he's actually
playing for the win
he's got the advantage he's not going to
let this one go
without a fight hikaru definitely on the
back foot he's got to worry about what
to do about his king
how do you defend the black king once
this pawn runs forward very aggressive
move there from wesley so
oh and a bad start to the day for hikaru
nakamura who just
he knows in the back of his head or even
in the front of his head he needs to win
games they definitely not lose them
yeah definitely not a loss would be the
most terrible thing actually because
then he would be one
point away from just being eliminated
because a draw is a
drawing the match is sufficient for
wesley so to go into the finals
yeah and there we see again above the
board we see this computer evaluation
the stockfish evaluation
um at the moment okay wesley so has
played the move recommended by the
computer giving white a two-point
advantage
that's equivalent to having two extra
pawns essentially
um on the board the material is level
both sides have equal pawns but white
pieces are so dominant that that just
gives him a huge advantage
and we see that again the computer
recommends just pushing a queen forward
one square just activating that queen as
kaya mentioned
move that queen forward get that last
rook into the game once wesley activates
that last rook
hikaru's pieces his weak king his pawns
they're all going to start feeling
very much under pressure this is all
going in white's favor wesley so
impressive stuff so far and he's playing
so quickly he's playing very quickly and
we actually have a question
from twitter from abdul majid who says
can you please tell us how to improve
chess calculation skills and how to
choose candidate moves for calculation
so very deep question there yeah i i
don't know if i even knew all the words
there candidate moves
candidate moves just refers to the moves
that you have available to you
because it can seem like you have a very
very long list but an actual fact there
is a very nice rule that can help you
and that would be you first look at
checks
and then you would look at captures and
then you would look at attacks
so those are and then you once you've
established that list
then you go through them you get very
very very methodical you go i'm gonna go
there there there
and uh yeah that's how that's kind of
the general rule in other kind of
positions
much more slower positions i wouldn't
suggest that you spend your time
calculating what would you do
is just like you suggested just
involving all your pieces you kind of
came up with this idea of moving the
queen to connect the rooks that is
brilliant you don't need to calculate
for that
just improve your pieces it's only when
the position is
sharp and you have to cut captures
and checks available on the board that's
right i
completely agree with your anchor even
grandmasters do this we look at the most
forcing types of moves
and the reason we look at checks and
captures are because if they work then
they can be very very strong they can
decide the game in your favor
if they don't work then okay then it's
time to improve a piece
i like to talk to my pieces ever since i
read a book i read a book when i was
young called the seven deadly chess sins
by jonathan rousen
and it talked about the mistakes that we
all make and the reasons behind those
mistakes
sometimes we forget to talk to our
pieces for example here wesley so he's
going to be talking to that rook on the
bottom right oh well sorry on the bottom
left hand
side of the board he's going to be
saying are you happy right now that
rick's going to say no
so he's going to improve it even if it
takes two or three minutes all right
well i guess you have to be a little bit
crazy to be great
well actually as wesley's always uh
thinking i know many people are
interested in this
what would you guys recommend the best
chess books for beginners
the best test books yeah for beginners
if you can both choose one book what
would you sort of
start reading ladies first ivanka while
i try and think of an answer
well okay the best actual paperback book
that i
ever read and it was when i was a child
i didn't really like to read
chess books there was one though that i
was absolutely
captivated by the drawings and it's
called chess for tigers
oh and it has all sorts of traps and
tricks and it had things like um
how to how to catch a heffalump which is
someone
who's someone that's much stronger than
you and then hold on winner the poor or
something
had another chapter on how to catch
bunnies they were the lower rated player
the
players are weaker than you and so i
that's the only book i've ever read like
cover to cover absolutely
so i absolutely recommend that but chess
for tigers yes for tigers but this is a
paperback book
nowadays there's you can kind of get a
lot more learning resources
online and these are better actually
well david how about you
yeah i remember reading a book called
how to beat your dad at chess oh
fantastic
i mean it might sound like it's for the
kids but actually uh i opened it up not
long ago again and it
just it gives you all the possible
checkmating patterns i think even for
more advanced players even for older
players
it's a great way to learn um and
actually i think wesley so he might be
trying to use some of those checkmate
patterns
highlighted in that book and we have a
queen move
reading my suggestions
along that diagonal and you can see how
he's trying to use
teamwork to make i love that quote
david i'm not going to let you forget it
to make the dream work
that's right so white's last move was to
just advance the queen forward two
squares it might look very innocent
right now
but once this white rook moves this
white rook could even threaten to
sacrifice itself
by giving a check or by taking a pawn
the whole idea
is to line up this bishop and the queen
against this weak pawn
this pawn is only defended by black's
king for example if black plays a
careless move here
if black just moves upon we see white
would be able to give checkmate
the rook would sacrifice itself and the
queen will jump the whole way up
and this black king now is trapped it
has no safe squares it cannot capture
the queen
which is nicely defended by its own
bishop white is already threatening some
huge attacks and therefore we see in the
game black decides to push his rook up
one square defending this weakness black
is up against it
wesley just pushing upon that the edge
um he's stopping a knight
from jumping forward to attack his queen
very calm stuff by wesley
he's been talking to that rook though
that rook is going to join the action
next move
double up with its friend team up and
all of white's pieces are controlling
the center
teamwork is the dreamer that will be the
next book that i buy the
the chess rhymes by ivanka david
and this is certainly a position that
will make wesley sews
supporters very happy and we do have a
tweet from
baz greene who says supporting wesley so
as we prefer the more attacking style of
play
chess champs and also he says watching
with my 11 year old son milo a future
world champion
fantastic bye my love all right we will
uh definitely follow mile overland
we definitely will great all right uh
well
it is hikaru nakamura thinking he is
under 10 minutes on the clock now not
dramatic yet but with the position he's
in i guess he can get there
that's right he will not have wanted to
start this game so badly with black
it's worth noting he didn't play the
opening he didn't
kind of start the game as he normally
does normally he's extremely solid he's
extremely hard to beat
he relies on an opening called the
berlin wall which is just
very very hard to put down but he knew
that drawing this
this game is probably not in he needs to
go for wesley so
i just love his reaction going
for an early stage he's i'm not going to
let you attack me i'm the one going to
be playing on the front foot i'm going
to put the pressure on you
and this early stage nakamura behind on
the clock
struggling on the board with a very weak
king yeah um
and you can see his facial expressions
he's not happy at all right now
yeah absolutely right there i mean i
really dislike
that black king it's got no pawn
protection and
that is super worrying and what also
really worries me
is the fact that if you take a look at
the bishops on the board they're
different colors
one is on the dark squares the other one
is on the light squares and that means
that white can start attacking on those
color squares and black really can't
defend those squares at all no that's
right
with those opposite color bishops that
ivanka mentions it always favors the
attacking side and
that at the moment is wesley so wesley
is the one going to try and attack
in return hikaru has pushed his king
towards the corner of the board
a very sensible move tucking his king
away there on a dark square
protected by his bishop potentially but
that won't change anything long term
it's just wesley sew's turn now to bring
that rook into the game we've mentioned
it for so long that
rook the bottom left hand corner of the
board
once that rook enters the action it's
going to be very hard for karu nakamura
to hold everything together he's got so
many weaknesses his
king his pawns um well he's got
weaknesses on both sides
and the left flank um and he's down on
time so it's uh kind of the whole
shebang here
that's right i mean he he was the
comeback king in the quarterfinals
against maxine vashilograf um hikara
nakamura he rode his luck in that one
but he did get there in the end he's
gonna need to ride his luck a bit here
today as well
yeah and we have to remind everyone that
this is a four
game match so the victor of those
four games will go well either either
we'll put it to a tie break or we'll go
through to the
to the finals if it's wesley that wins
it or draws so
he only needs a draw in those four games
hikaru nakamura he needs at least one
win
it all comes down to what wesley so does
and if wesley so wins this game
then wow hikaru nakamura needs to come
back with a win in the next game where
it's
almost over yeah yeah wesley will be on
the brink of victory and
it's very rare to see him um see him
crumble under the pressure really so
hikaru knows that he's he'll be
completely up against it
um if he loses this first game he needs
to just dig deep try and defend
as best he can wesley in the meantime
thinking for a couple of minutes here
i'm slightly surprised i would have just
brought my rook into the game and then
only started to
really think calculate once all my
pieces are centralized and in the action
we talked about calculation there
earlier with ivanka and normally
those checks those captures that we
always look for they tend to work
one only once all your pieces are
coordinated together so
i'm slightly surprised whether is having
a think here
maybe he's just recomposing he knows
he's in control
oh and he has played
the queen and he lined up against the
rook but i think that queen has
others in his head is he not happy with
that move
no i think he i think this is a great
move
although ideally i would have done what
david does i would have also been there
just picked up that rook and brought it
along the same
line as the rook but this one i think is
really sinister because this queen move
is actually threatening to join
in an attack along against the king
and i'm thinking if that queen can get
to a square opposite the king
on the right hand side of the board then
that she's gonna be
so good there she's gonna eat pawns and
it's gonna
almost be game over right that's right
if we bring up the board we can see
wesley so his
plan over the next two moves he's going
to try his last move
bring the queen across just shuffling
across one square that queen is headed
for new
well very um kind of
well just great pastures really trying
to think of a word to describe
i mean that queen is going to be so
powerful if she reaches opposite the
black king
um and once she gets there she's not
going to turn back let's face it
exactly that queen once she penetrates
uh the black territory once she enters
the black camp
it's going to be very hard to guard
against and also
just if wesley so gets the time to take
a time out
to spend an extra move these three
pieces together the two rooks and the
queen
on the same line that's like an
unstoppable oh wow
yeah three of them in the same line i
mean you always
cheer for or you're always happy when
you see one player get two of them in
the same line
but three of them three is just magical
you know there's so much pressure
oh look at wesley seems like he's
giggling
he does have cats maybe one of the cats
has entered the room just to support him
maybe zanzibar zanzibar oh yes we got to
know stanzi by the
cats which he loves a lot and he is
just uh he's just in a very good
position here in the very first game and
hikaru nakamura
has been thinking for some time now he
is soon going under six minutes
on the clock as he is fighting to
survive in this game is there any chance
he can still win
this um he needs he needs a blunder
probably
he needs he needs a blunder he needs
wesley to start making some bad
decisions
so um but at the minute it's looking
very very very good for
wesley yeah and then we see the
stockfish evaluation as well above the
board
hikaru's problem is here that okay he's
found one of the best moves
the problem is no matter what he plays
wesley's advantage is
guaranteed and more importantly than
that it's just
very easy for white to play white has
many possible moves
we can see there that the computer
recommends pushing a pawn in the center
of the board
he can also just improve his bishop he
can improve his rook just very car moves
and they all give white a big advantage
it's not just about the material it's
not about what pawns and pieces are on
the board it's also about which position
is easier to play
if white's plans are more simple and
more straightforward then wesley can
play them quickly
and nakamura will be the one burning
time on the clock having to react
yeah i think everything is in wesley's
favor right now but he is spoiled for
choice
and that might be the only thing that
makes him pause
all right well wesley so is thinking in
this first game of the day semi-final
match
two and he won day one so he should feel
very comfortable here
all right what are we expecting from him
oh
and he's really pushing for it the pawn
has advanced and is now attacking the
knight and the pawn
and the great thing is because of the
rook and the queen lined
up against that pawn then black cannot
cannot actually capture that pawn
because
of that's right so if white's last move
was to push the pawn forward attacking
this knight attacking this pawn
as ivanka mentioned this pawn cannot be
captured now if black takes this pawn
this would be a huge mistake a huge
blunder we see the queen and rook lined
up
white would just capture a rook winning
the black queen this rook is defended by
white zone queen
wesley so taking advantage of this
black's knight has been forced to
retreat to the edge of the board
that's the most depressing sight for
chess when a knight has to retreat
um and wesley so just snaps a pawn off
he's winning now
this pawn is attacking the black rook
this rook has to just
step across look how strong this pawn is
if white can maintain this pawn
then white will be completely in control
i would just suggest
dropping the bishop forward one square
gang kind of over protecting this pawn
that pawn is a thorn in black side yeah
just look at how that
pawn is just cramping the whole back
army look at it the pawn is worth one
point and the rick is worth five
that's another rook is worth another
five so that's one versus
ten and then you add the knight in there
because that knight can't move either
so suddenly that white one pawn is
holding
all these huge pieces and yeah it's just
a terrible terrible game and he's done
it
he's done it he has moved his bishop to
protect that very important pawn
and wow i i think we are going to see
the game
and not that not that far off yeah
black is almost paralyzed that one pawn
that one
white horn deep inside his camp like you
said ivanka
is completely dominating the whole of
the black army
black is just having to wait and hope
that white can't break through
but all of black's pieces i mean they're
stuck they're all on his
beginning ranks his first ranks um
yeah i think white is just going to
finally improve that
rook on the bottom left well he's being
forced to now because
hikaru has taken a pawn with a bishop
and now the rook
must move but note how the rook actually
moves to another
open line so he say wesley so really
wants to use
all his rooks into the game and what he
wants to do is he wants to bulldoze
those rooks that are in the way of that
very very important pawn and yeah
impressive stuff
and it's not only ourselves finding
wesley's play impressive
we also have a tweet from jurgen lutz
who says
the ease with which wesley sews play is
frightening isn't it hashtag chess
champs so remember if you do want to
join in the conversation we're having a
lot of fun in the studio
please you can do this by tweeting us on
the hashtag chesschamps
definitely right and that last tweet it
hits the nail on the head wesley he just
seems to be in the flow we've seen
magnus carson talk about the flow it's
just when you see things and you're so
confident you just put moves down on the
board you improve your pieces everything
just seems to work in your favor and
wesley so he's done that he's
centralized all of his pieces his rook
in the middle his queen in the middle
his other rook now joining the action
everything just seems to be working in
his favor
meanwhile nakamura he's spending a lot
of time on the clock his pieces are
stuck
we see his black bishop there is not
coordinated with any of the rest of his
army
his bishop is very far away from his
queen his rooks
all of black's pieces they're lacking
that cohesion and therefore white
springs forward with his knight he's
smelling blood
he senses the kill that's a very strong
move that night edging further towards
the black king
i i i think yovanka is going to be spot
on with her prediction
that king is not gonna last long without
any cover like that and i just love
wesley's play you know
here he's moved his knight forward and
now
i think wesley will be calculating
whether that knight
can give a check so here there are a few
captures on the board and there's a few
checks
so here's the time to kind of sit back
and try and do some calculation
that's right wesley so he had his
glasses off he's put them back on he
knows this is the critical moment he
senses it
um he's fidgeting a bit but that's
because he's getting excited he
senses that there's a way to get at the
black king and i think there is actually
a direct way to win this game
um maybe if we bring up the board we can
see black's last move
bringing a knight towards the center
white wants to jump in and give check
with his own knight but that black
knight defends this square
therefore it's time to get rid of a
defender i think wesley he can sacrifice
his rook for this night
giving up five points giving up that
rook for a night which is normally worth
three points
but more importantly removing a defender
from the board and then white's knight
is going to jump in
and deliver the killing blow to the
black king uh wesley so he's spoiled for
choice here
but i think he's going to find it that's
the kind of move he'd be looking for
as ivanka mentioned earlier we look for
those checks we look for those captures
the winning move here is a capture and
he's done it and he's done it and he's
and that's uh he looks completely
shocked
by that move okay so hikaru has
taken the rook we are expecting wesley
so to suddenly
use that knight and jump in with a check
that's right so white could jump in with
his knight but also he could shuff white
could shuffle his rook across just one
square
attacking the black queen before jumping
in with that knight oh even better
use every single piece in the book yeah
exactly using every piece
nearly every move here gives a big
advantage hikaru shaking his head
he knows that white is going to move in
for the kill wesley's jumped in with his
knight
maybe not quite the best move but should
be good enough
um here black is going to have to get
rid of that knight that knight is too
deep inside the black camp now
um that night giving check if nakamura
moves his king his king will be forced
out into the open where it will get
checkmated
um for example if he moves his king
forward one square that king will get
checkmated immediately
whereas um hikaru nakamura just needs to
give up his rook here for that night and
he's done it
giving up the rook but look at that pawn
it is
one square away from a queening and
what's worse
is that that pawn is protected by the
bishop it's on a light square as well so
it can never ever be captured oh this is
i i i honestly expect hikaru to resign
in the next few moves oh
really when he can't do anything about
that uh
that porn and all he can do is just pass
with the bishop and just kind of go um
yeah that last move by black maybe if we
bring up the analysis board
um that last move by black he's just
trying to blockade it's all about
whether wesley so can break through
black is just passive he's defending
look at this queen blocking a pawn
queens are the worst blockaders
they want to be active zooming around
the board um on open lines open
diagonals black's queen is passive this
black king is helpless in the corner
this black bishop just
trying to coordinate with these forces
meanwhile
white has this monster pawn this pawn is
one square away from becoming
a queen all white needs to do is remove
this blockade there's a few ways to do
this he doesn't need to rush though
wesley so
it's in complete control i would think
about eventually
trying to get rid of blacks blockader
but
maybe first it's time to start winning
some pawns yeah that's what i was
that was my instinct when those pawns on
the left-hand side of the board
make my make a second past pawn
a pawn which has no opposition and he's
gone for the pawns
on the right hand side of the board
those weren't necessarily the ones i
would have gone for
but uh still the position is so good
oh and hikaru is looking so
uncomfortable there is it only a matter
of moves now before he just
gives this up i think so i do think so
i i think the problem is is that these
bishops
it's all to do with these bishops black
bishop is on the dark squares white
bishops on the light squares they're
opposite color
they cannot ever meet and there's just
no
way that wesley is going to be losing
that
monster pawn on the on the right hand
side of the board
and when it's one point one square away
from queening my goodness
yeah that that white pawn next to the
black king right now that pawn
it's going to be there for the rest of
the game uh it's just impossible to get
rid of it
it's like having literally having a
thorn in your side you can just never
remove it you're always uncomfortable
you always have to worry about that pawn
it's going to tie down the black king
the black queen meanwhile white there we
see he's just pushed the pawn in front
of his king
wesley he's just going to use those
pawns to shelter his own king
while his queen and bishop will do the
hard work to win this game
very calm move there from wesley so it
shows he's not in a rush
and rightly so black just black's
paralyzed
he has no productive plan in this
position he pushes a pawn forward
i don't think that helps change anything
white still has
complete control here white can do
literally anything he can go for the
kill immediately he can try and
get his pawn up towards the end make
another queen
or he can just sit and wait and really
torture hikaru nakamura
and we can see on hikaru nakamura's face
he is definitely not happy in this
position he has gone under
four minutes so there's not a lot of
time for him either to save this
position and
i mean maybe there's not even chances at
all for him to save this
no there's no there's not too many
chances the only hope because
remember when you are playing a bad
position you always have to have a very
positive
mindset you can't just be a bit
defeatist so the only hope for hikaru is
if the queens come off then
maybe just maybe we get into an opposite
color bishop end game
and those are very very renowned for
their drawing tendencies
but there's just no way that wesley so
is ever going to do that
i think the one thing that i've really
learned from this tournament is that
if you are in a better position do not
switch the queens off the board
just keep them so birthday so will
probably keep them it's my bet
yes that's completely right kyle that's
an important lesson for everyone at home
as well
especially if you have the safer king
yeah sometimes trading queens is okay
when you're better but as long as it
makes the position more simple and you
have enough pieces left to win
um but if you're attacking if you have a
safer king um
there's this never trade the queen
there's a there's a nasty
trick on the board
for for wesley so if hikaru nakamura
is careless then wesley is going to play
the move so
um yeah so for example wesley so he's
just it looks like he's just attacking
these
pawns on the left side if black moves
one of these pawns if he's careless
if he forgets about his king ivanka the
winning move i've seen it you've seen it
i haven't seen it it's to do with the
check always look for checks and
captures first
you can do this all right uh does it
have something to do with the queen
the white queen yes yes all right well
maybe the first move okay
you guys have to tell me it's about this
x-ray attack against the black king
uh-huh
so you need to remove this pawn in order
to get the black things
yes of course therefore making a new
queen
actually sacrificing this port now it's
a double check a double attack against
the black king the black king has to
move it has to take this queen
and now and now the bishop and the queen
coordinate match up the squares
and they coordinate on one point and
it's
right opposite the black king and that
is
checkmate that's right and that is why
hikaru nakamura he doesn't want to play
this move but he's had to retreat to
break
the break the tension along this line
against the black king
hikaru trying to defend but wesley he
can just capture everything on the left
side of the board now
if he wants to he can start snacking on
pawns or he can just
maintain complete control um lots and
lots of ways for wesley so to win this
game
he's going to be setting up tricks like
that last one small threats here and
there
eventually nakamura he's going to be so
low on time that he won't be able to
stop
those tricks forever and wesley so a
very classy move just bringing his
bishop to the center of the board
now he captures no he captures yeah and
uh
hikaru desperately trying to control the
squire in front of that
monster pawn on the right hand side of
ward oh
that's right and wesley slowly advancing
he's in a very
sadistic mood right now he wants to just
torture
her nakamura nakamura looks like he got
shocked there
i think he's i think i think this is yes
and then
so he wesley gave a little check there
and the black king is forced to take a
step
up the board but now the question is is
there anything
forcing that's right black's king now is
completely out in the open
white is a pawn up at that monster pawn
up
right at the top of the board white has
that extra pawn white has four pawns
versus three pawns
black's king is also i mean that king is
just
ripe for um i mean it's not gonna
survive essentially
compared to the white king nicely
protected by two white pawns
yeah and because wesley has oh he's just
blessing with him
he's just doing he's just repeating the
position twice not to take a draw
but simply to get some extra time on the
clock
and there you go he has made his
bid for victory wishing the queen
all the way to the top of the right hand
side of the board that's right so white
just toying with his i mean wesley he's
playing with his food here he brought
his queen into the enemy camp
he's retreating the queen now he's just
looking for weaknesses
eventually hikaru he's gonna have to
defend on the right the left the center
eventually he won't be able to decide
one of the uh defend one of the plan
one of the flanks sorry um and white's
queen now is attacking a pawn on the
left side
yes um yeah no i mean it does look like
wesley so is wasting time but what he's
really doing is he's just building up
time
on the clock and he's just indicating it
to hikaru nakamura that
he's in no rush he can enjoy his
position for as long as he wants to
and he can make some small improvements
and hikaru is just
helpless cannot do a thing that's right
hikaru has had to retreat his queen now
to its starting square
it's actually black's queen is on its
starting square black's bishop is on his
starting square
black's king is out in front of the army
it should never be that way no you
should
never have a spartan king no way
all right well hikaru nakamura he is
probably about to
lose his first game and that is
devastating for him as he did also lose
day one but in the match between magnus
carlsen and jana pogniacci
the russian has won
one and is about to come back on day two
so
much interesting stuff happening that's
absolutely thrilling stuff because
there is i wouldn't i wouldn't have
predicted it at the start of
this round but i did think yeah i do
think magnus can easily do it but he
started off
with a loss so we'll see magnus has to
come back fighting but definitely
and so he car nakamura also has to come
back fighting but
probably it will be in the next game is
there anything he can do here
he just has to pray now he's just making
moves with his king
it just it's all about whether wesley so
can find that knockout blow
he's been maybe messing around a bit
slightly with his queen
not really going for the kill
immediately he's just teasing
nakamura but wesley he just has to make
sure he doesn't wait too long he can't
let the moment pass
he can't get too low on time and get
nervous he does gain 10 seconds after
every move so
he's picked up he's picked up a minute
or two just by giving a few checks here
and there
but it's time to use that queen time to
use that bishop to coordinate
together um we see on the board here i
think it's time to just bring that queen
closer to the black king um this queen
needs to coordinate the queen needs to
attack on the dark squares
the bishop needs to attack on the light
squares instead he shuffles his queen
across one square i like that one
he's maybe going to zoom up the board
and give a check or
another very i mean very dangerous idea
to bring his queen to the top of the
board and start attacking some black
pieces
defended by this monster pawn we've been
talking about hikaru
trying to defend i mean he's trying his
best he's done a very good job of
surviving but it shouldn't be enough in
the end
yeah hikaru is just waiting for the end
to come
and wesley so with that last queen move
is now
attacking that pawn on the left-hand
side and he's just given up that pawn
is there some trick i don't think
there's any trick behind it he's just
simply accepted that
that pawn is dead that's right so white
is about to capture
black's remaining pawn down the left
flank um we see
white does capture that pawn hikara
nakamura he's trying
a final trick he's going for the white
king but that white king has too
many defenders around it ah there's
plenty of
choice here wesley so he jumps up with
this queen attacking the black bishop
um i'm not sure about that one i would
like to centralize my queen now as white
if i can
white's queen is a bit offside there in
the corner of the board black's king
just dropping back to
protect the bush uh protect the bishop
yeah
and uh now i think we're going to see
hikaru
try to remove some of the protection
that is
surrounding the white king okay he's
moved his queen
oh he doesn't look too happy about his
move
or maybe the entire position here he's
shaking his head and
definitely so he's he's trying to set up
so he's holding in reserve moves like
porn takes porn
and wesley himself has played pawn takes
pawn
so he is not afraid he thinks that he is
king is entirely safe and he can just
remove material
and yeah you can see it wesley is three
pawns
what is it one two three i always have
to count three pawns up that's good
counting ivanka
sometimes i fell on the most basic thing
that's important to check these things
to make sure we're always uh kind of up
to date with how things develop
i mean white does have those four pawns
against the black blacks one so
actually wesley's now maybe he is open
to a
queen trade white just has so many pawns
pawns on the right and the left they
will
be too much they will overwhelm the
black army um
black's bishop they're just advancing
one square but wesley
bringing his queen across um black
capturing a pawn
i think the end is nigh now white has a
few ways to win white could give a check
with his queen he could
if he wants to keep things simple it's
time to push that pawn on the left side
and that pawn has no rival now yeah and
he gives a check
giving a check and now he has to defend
the bishop in the center of the board he
cannot let that bishop be lost
and he's done that by retreating the
queen diagonally
that's right so white now actually
threatening to push that monster pawn
that pawn was threatening to become a
queen so black blocks
the line of the white and it's happening
david he is pushing
that pawn on the left-hand side it is
three squares away from
queening and that i think is gonna
signal the end
that's right now it's a question of will
hikaru nakamura allow us to see
three queens on the board will he give
up will he resign before that
well that would be fun if he would let
us do that but uh and he is actually he
does have more time on the clock now
than wesley so but
we see on the bar there this is
completely winning for wesley so
yeah that's right sometimes we try not
to trust the bar unless we're 100 sure
because the computer it might see things
that humans can't see that
us humans we find very difficult to spot
but wesley i mean here
it's not just the two extra pawns it's
the fact he has two potential queens
coming on the board
and two extra potential queens as well
as his existing queen
um white's pawns racing towards the end
there nakamura
trying to give some checks we see his
last move he just shuffled his coin
across
he wants to give some checks uh whoops
he wants to give some checks now
to the white king um and actually we've
seen wesley so has allowed that wesley
so
has he blundered i think i think we need
to see the players now
um maybe wesley so i think he's alive
he's allowed a perpetual check
wesley so he's blunted we're speechless
here in the studio
no i can't believe it wesley so
that's the most and they have repeated
the position it ends in a draw this has
been completely winning for wesley so
absolutely
absolutely he just needed to be careful
as to where to put the king
and unbelievable i mean i was just
really shocked by wesley's last move and
very careless i cannot believe
how lucky hikaru nakamura got there and
he just
bounced off he knows it's 15 minutes
until the next game
and he got so lucky in this first game
yes
absolutely lucky i mean there's just
nothing for it i mean i
and look at this this is the reaction
when wesley realizes he has made a
huge blunder in a winning position
and let's see what hikaru nakamura looks
like
oh that's not nice
come on it looks like that's what he's
saying
oh yeah just laughing he realizes he got
extremely lucky there and this makes
everything so much more interesting
because with a draw here
well then nakamura still has all to play
for
um and i would love david to just go
into the position because it all was so
faster
where did um wesley so blunder this
that's right so it was only
it was just before the end it all
happened so suddenly wesley so
completely winning position ivanka and i
we were expecting the game to end
not in a draw we were expecting the game
to end very quickly in a white win
and it's just he walked into a perpetual
check it meant that the white king could
not escape from being checked forever
um in this position white has several
winning moves why could just move his
queen away to give space to his king
he could also just push a pawn and this
pawn is very close to
getting to the end of the board black
here could try and give some checks with
his queen
but it wouldn't be enough the white king
could just walk away the white king
could sidestep
instead he moved his queen to the center
normally that's a very sensible move
um normally we always say centralize
your queen the queen is extremely
powerful there
but this allowed a check attacking the
white king the king has to run away
we saw another check and this must be
what wesley
had just forgotten about he thought
maybe he could block with his queen here
but if the queen blocks
suddenly black can take this bishop this
bishop is undefended in the middle of
the board
um wesley so must have forgotten that
instead he had to move his king
and after a couple more checks he found
he couldn't escape
there's just no way to run away um
shocking developments
literally any move i think well almost
any move was winning apart from what he
chose
wow um shocking stuff there i'm still a
bit speechless
and we know he did have quite a little
time on his clock but it wasn't
it wasn't that hard for him to
i mean the clock wasn't that pushy for
him um was it just
too confident here for wesley so yeah i
think he forgot the most fundamental
rule which is that you protect
your king you always worry about your
monarch especially when the queens are
on the board
and like kyle on twitter says wow
that blunder it's absolutely at least me
speechless too i
didn't expect that all right well we
have had
the most interesting start to day two of
semi-finals and this
is what the standings look like after
round
one so magnus carlsen he won day one but
he lost
game one of day two against janna
pogniacci and that means that if young
neponia she can just keep pushing for
draws now
we will have tie breaks in that matchup
and then hikaru nakamura he lost day one
and then he looked like he was
completely losing in game one that would
have been devastating
wesley so blundered and here they are
they had a draw in the first game so
still
all to play for for hikaru nakamura and
i mean hikarna nakamura must be feeling
quite lucky quite happy right now but
yana pogba actually david how do you
think he's feeling
apparently actually he must be on top of
the world right now i mean yesterday he
had such a hard day he had
so many winning chances he just couldn't
finish them off and today
he's taking advantage of the fact that
magnus carlsen is a bit of a slow
starter
um he's pounced and i think we're going
to see the best of carlsen now napoli
actually
if you can keep that up it's going to be
a fantastic fight it's hard to call a
winner
all right well we will follow that game
between minus carl's nina pognache in
the next round it's starting in a few
minutes before it all starts
let's shake up round one and uh let's
hear from the chess players would they
rather
never travel again or never i think it's
win a chess tournament again this year
[Music]
oh never travel any other country hands
down i have seen
i think 35 to 50 something around those
countries and i'm satisfied
but i need to win more i would say never
travel chess is more important
chess is one of the most important
things in my life the end of the day
winning is all that matters
i don't know the thing is that
if you don't travel to other country
maybe you don't win tournaments this is
the easiest one
i don't need to travel to any other
country
i can sacrifice that but i have to win
some chess tournament
no uh oh
no i think i'm fine i'm not traveling
all right well magnus cars luckily he
said he would easily give up travel
and definitely win some more chester and
eventually i mean
we have this year with the kovid been
missing traveling
a lot what would you choose never travel
again or never win a chess tournament
again
never win a chess storm again uh i
haven't won so many chess tournaments
how well you best
british women's champions nine times to
have that one now you have to
write a lot that's true but i i you know
i i would give up the traveling
you would get it i'm giving the
traveling yeah all right well luckily
magnus carlsen
uh we did hear from him in this piece uh
he chose
never travel again um and that's good
because he could be winning the skilling
open the first tournament
in the champions chess tour but he had a
horrible start to this day david
losing against jana pognyarchy what
happened in that game that's right it
was actually a crazy game it was so up
and down both sides winning at different
points
actually this was the critical moment we
see black has actually sacrificed a
piece magnus carlsen playing black in
this game
janam pomnicci with the white pieces
black has sacrificed a piece
but the first thing we notice is that
white king is out in the open this king
no defenders around it normally ivanka's
mentioned this we call it spartan king
leading from the front
we don't want that we want our king
nicely safe and tucked away behind some
pawns
magnus carlsen had a winning move in
this position he could have just shifted
his queen across
indirectly attacking the white king if
the king's sidesteps black could now
trap the white queen
this queen is now well he only has one
safe square
the queens would the queen would have to
retreat and once the queens get
exchanged
black wins a rook at the end black has a
winning position instead
magnus carlsen missed that moment he
captured a pawn he got a bit greedy
but white just sidestepped with his king
this king we saw started to run away
and white's extra knight was the
deciding factor big missed opportunity
for magnus and it swung the whole 360
for the pony actually to win that one
wow and ivanka we know jana pogbachie he
did a comeback in the quarter-finals and
it must be amazing for him to start the
day off like this
yes it must be very satisfying because
he had so many wish missed opportunities
yesterday but you know you can't
write off magnus carlsen i've seen him
lose his first game and then
come back uh fighting and win two games
in a row so i don't know i'm not going
to discount him
so very exciting actually that we are
following this next game david because
we
might see um magnus carlsen i think he's
with white pieces
really going to i mean show that he's
better than this yeah i mean asia
vancouver mentioned he's a wounded
animal right now he's
his pride has been wounded he needs to
fight back he knows he wasn't at his
best yesterday despite winning
magnus he needs to turn things around
and normally that's what motivates him
adversary
and he always brings his best when he
needs to
all right well round two of day two of
semifinals
is about to start magnus carlsen one day
one but he lost
game one of day two so jana pogniacci is
feeling full of confidence between
before game two and wesley so
well he could have won game one it ended
in a draw
and we will soon see hikaru nakamura
joining that game
and he needs to start winning if he
wants to tie
go to tie breaks with wesley so magnus
carlton looking
very concentrated before game two
humankind
he's always looking very comp but now he
looks especially fierce
yeah he is very motivated and i really
expect him to come back
oh already have you been on this other
hot lines in magnus
and advising him on his opening choices
this is an opening that
david is a very very famous one okay
that's right so we have seen an opening
called the sicilian defense which means
white pushes her pawn in front of his
king two squares
and black meets it by pushing pawn in
front of his bishop in return
white on his second move he moved a pawn
just we call it the c3 sicilian because
of the coordinate the square
that white moved his pawn to on the
second move i've actually been playing
this since i was five years old i've
played it against magnus carlsen i've
actually played it against janna
pogbiechi as well
magnus he nearly never opens this way
with white i saw he did it yesterday
against napoliacci but it's so rare for
him it means that he's trying to
surprise his opponent he has a special
idea in mind have you been on the phone
with either
cease to david no comment okay
well then i have to ask who is a white
or black hair
um sort of pushing it into this exact
opening
uh it's definitely magnus carson yeah
okay well then we know who you were on
the phone
all right well ladies and gentlemen you
should really expect some great
commentary from
david howell now because he's the expert
maybe even the one
chose this opening for magnus carlsen
what's happening
that's right so no pressure then for me
um
we see a lot of stuff happening on the
board a set of bishops have been traded
more importantly white has pushed his
king to the right side of the board
white has castled first and in this
exact line of the sicilian
of the c3 sicilian that we mentioned
it's all about black's king black's king
is in the middle of the board
it doesn't want to push itself towards
the left because it will never be safe
that side
black's left side of the board is
actually very open black needs to put
his king on the right side
but at the moment it's blocked by a
bishop and that's why we see magnus
carson go on the attack he's pushed upon
his corner pawn in front of the rook on
the left side he's going to push forward
that pawn even more to start attacking
black's knights
to start opening things up before jana
ponnichi can get his king to safety
i love this line for white personally i
think it's extremely
difficult for black to handle we see
stockfish the computer evaluations as
well
above the board black has a few moves
they're all fine
but it's not they're not easy they're
not human moves to find
black's best moves now are actually to
move pieces which have already moved
once before to move a knight to move a
queen um we see black has
napolita he's decided to drop back with
his queen because this queen would soon
be attacked by a white rook
but for black the main problem is this
bishop this bishop cannot move right now
it cannot be developed and as long as
this bishop cannot be developed
black's king can never get to safety um
it's all the race
can white get an attack going before
black's king
king jumps to safety there and we see a
couple more moves
wow and magnus pushing that pawn all the
way up yeah he is pushing that pawn hard
isn't he
completely all the way up the board and
i really like his next move he has
taken a stake in the center by advancing
his
pawn and just look at it so he really
wants to open up the position as quickly
as possible because this pawn
is challenging it's black counterpart
wow this position really is gonna
heat up because it's all about can white
start doing things before the black king
has moved to safety by castling
and obviously magnus carlsen is in very
known territory
he's uh almost two minutes up from what
he started with so he's playing
extremely fast
that's right we see more action a set of
knights have left the board now as well
and white has jumped forward with his
queen
i love that move it means that black
cannot develop we talked about this
bishop
if we bring up the analysis board
black's bishop is still paralyzed it
still
cannot develop itself white's last move
bring this queen forward
at the moment that's the only white
piece that is attacking but
it's attacking a very weak point the
square only defended by black bishop
black wants to get his king to safety
but moving this bishop would lose a pawn
now
this pawn would be undefended and now we
see black decide to push a pawn
in front of his rook attacking this
queen but now if black ever wants to
bring his king this side castle to the
right-hand side of the board now his
king will never be safe because this
pawn will always be a weakness
this is fascinating stuff i'd love to
say i've studied this exact position
before but i would be lying
brand new as far as i can as far as i
can tell both players freestyling both
players
feeling really aggressive i think magnus
wants to win napoleon
he's not happy with the one point lead
he wants to push even more
yeah this is brilliant brilliant play
and psychology
by magnus carlsen because yes black has
advanced that pawn on the right hand
side of borden's attacking the white
queen
but like david said if that once that
queen moves
there is just no safe place for the
black king to go and that is going to
cause nepali actually so much discomfort
and i really adore the kind of human
psychology because although
the computers might always go well the
position is
no completely level 0.00
until infinity there is just so much
play
and in fact twitter is also
complementing
the human aspect of chess so we do have
a tweet from benz poliak he says
wesley sews blunder in the last game is
the reason why chess will always be
better with humans playing
and again we have a tweet from carl
portman agreeing chess is a human game
despite computers being
infinitely better mistakes can be made
at any time and thank heavens for it
that's right there's definitely beauty
in imperfection and
we've seen that the games are so
exciting because of this rapid time
control because of the online format
there are mistakes that
there is drama um i i personally i love
watching computers play
because uh just they come up with such
creative ideas especially modern
computers but it will never compare to
human chats
um just the human psychology as well i
mean the psychology of this match alone
this
this one head-to-head battle um it's so
intense
yeah exactly it's just like the human
psychology just kind of like
pressurizing your opponent and pushing
them
forcing them giving them choices and
yeah
you can see an epomy actually has now
advanced spawn on the left hand side
of the board wasn't wouldn't have been a
move that i expected i would have
perhaps focused
myself on development i'm looking at the
bishop that is
all at home but uh okay
he has advanced his pawn on the left
hand side of the board and
black is trying to gain space that's
right so black is trying to gain space
on that left side
um meanwhile white has to decide how do
i improve my pieces at the moment
only white's queen is beyond his first
his first rank his first line
um his bish we see on the left side
there white's rook is still asleep
white's knight and bishop are still
asleep
it's time to bring those into the game
personally i would want to bring my
knight in now
there's a rule i was taught when i was
young nights before bishops
it's a very general rule sometimes you
want to develop those bishops first but
i would be wanting to improve my night
uh for one and okay magnus is sat here
listening
he knows the rule nights before bishops
and if you note the knight has moved to
the edge of the board and the reason why
the knight moved there is first of all
it's attacking that
pawn that black has just advanced but
also it doesn't want to get in the way
of the bishop that was trying was has a
nice clean diagonal okay and
nepomniacci has in fact taken that
knight
and magnus has taken that bishop with
the rook
that's right so a fair trade there
bishop for night both roughly worth the
same amount
but the pieces remaining on the board
that's what the
i mean those are the important factors
black's knight nicely centralized in the
middle there
white's bishop's still at home but it
that white bishop is controlling many
squares that the black knight wants to
jump to
personally i like white's position very
i mean only slightly because white's
king is safer white's king is nicely
tucked away
behind those pawns on the right side
black's king is still in the middle
it still needs to make a big decision
where it wants to hide
um i think magnus he'll be happy with
the outcome of the opening there's still
enough pieces left enough tension left
and he has the safer king we saw in that
last game when napolita won
king safety it's a double-edged sword it
can go either way but as long as magnus
has the safer king
yeah he'll be happy i have to say i love
michaelis's position
i'm going to go a bit further because i
because of the reason that you just said
because of this
unsafe king napolita is going to be
so tortured by that fact where is that
king going to go to and he would
and this is where the kind of the
psychology comes into play and he will
try
maybe even play the inaccurate moves
doing everything possible to try to get
that king into safety
and uh yeah i am loving white's position
well actually i'm talking about
psychology
just always in a chess game i guess
psychology is a big factor but is it
even more of a factor in every game that
magnus carlsen plays
seeing yesterday's game where jana
pomnyacci just he was never able to
get wins in winning positions is that
typical
psychology in games with magnus carlsen
yeah i mean among our fellow
professional players we do talk about
the magnus effect he just has this
kind of aura around him sometimes you
get winning positions you know
you've got him up against the wall you
know you only need two or three moves to
win but somehow
it's so hard to finish him off um yeah
it's just so hard to break through his
defenses janupomnechi
experienced that yesterday two
completely winning positions
anyone else in the world he would have
won those games um but because he
wouldn't make those inaccuracies
against anyone else in the world is that
what you're saying yeah basically i mean
the thing is if you defeat magnus that
has such
power and such kudos you get really
excited and you start to kind of get
this
when you see the wind coming so exactly
and you start to stress about things
there's also the question that you know
that you're playing magnus carlsen and
you start to second-guess yourself well
why is the world champion playing this
perhaps he's seen one move
more than me so i'm going to double
check my lines and therefore i'm going
to use a little bit more time on the
clock
and those are the things that kind of
lead to those
big mistakes and we saw that yesterday i
i really really believe
that napoli nepomnierci would have
beaten anyone else in that position
but because it was magnus but then
apparently he learned from it coming
back
with a strong win in the first game
today but
this time magnus carlsen is in the lead
though yeah it was a slightly different
game
because in that in the first game we saw
that there was a very very sharp
game and because magnus played
inaccurately he could react to that
and then because his hand was forced we
saw a kind of situation where there was
just no coming back for magnus because
magnus was a knight down
so yeah different situations yeah well
so much psychology going on in these
chess games and that makes it so much
more interesting and
i think both players made a move as we
were talking david
that's right so um actually black's just
made a move and magnus carson he's been
thinking for two minutes now so napoli
actually
has just pushed a pawn forward and if we
bring up the board we can see his plan
with his last move it looks like a
weakening move we don't like pushing
pawns in front of our king
but i think this is very clever black
pushes a pawn he's just created
a bit of a hole a very safe square for
his king now if magnus carson just makes
a move just a random move black will put
his king on this square protected
very nicely by pawns more importantly
his rook still protects this pawn so
white's queen cannot get into the
position right now
um personally i think that's a very
clever choice by napoliyachi he's found
a very safe
kind of hiding place for his king and
that's what the battle will
be about in the next five ten moves
can't white get to that king
yeah and we have a very great treat
tweet from
chesabu he says magnus follows johann
sebastian christiansen's chessball
the on the c3 sicilian for the first 14
moves before deviating
with a different 15th move was this the
best move
so magnus has been watching some
participle courses and chessboard
is the training website and also um it's
a great website
you can there's many books online and it
also has this
really unique thing where you can
practice
your chest openings and your chest books
and your chest in-game techniques using
the science of space repetition and so
using this kind of really lovely thing
it actually pinpoints your strengths and
your weaknesses
and it identifies okay well you have to
improve that and it will force you to
repeat it again and again
and i have actually been into chessable
a little bit because i want to improve
my chess skills a lot and
i do know they have black fridays it was
all weekend
so good chance to get some great courses
at a great price there this weekend
wow i mean if it's good enough for the
world champion i think it's good i know
yes um i know the first thing i'm going
to be doing when i get back to my
room tonight i'm going to be going on
chess ball buying this course on this
opening
just to compare it just to see what
magnus carson's been studying
well and you might also call magnus
carlsen if you're
happy with how he plays your opening
that's right that's right and um we have
seen a couple of moves
black has just retreated his knight from
the center now
um for magnus carlsen that will be a
small gain and we also see the bar there
under magnus carson it's zoomed slightly
over towards the white side
so black's move retreating this knight
away from the center of the board
i'm not a big fan it had to defend the
pawn but
that's not a good uh sign for black you
want your knight in the center
ivanka calls it an octo knight
controlling eight squares that knight
now
isn't controlling half as many um
white's pieces
look very nicely placed maybe the bishop
can jump forward to attack that knight
lots of possible ideas here maybe if we
bring up the board just briefly
we can see a very strong move here i
think for white just bringing the bishop
forward
attacking this knight this night feels
like the key defensive piece
i would want to get rid of that if i can
also i would want to try and stop the
black knight taking this pawn maybe
yeah i think it's magnus carson he's got
the advantage he just needs to play
energetically
he can't wait for too long for black to
get his king into safety yeah he
definitely can't wait he needs to use
the momentum he has
the attack which means that he is the
one putting pressure on the position
and if he sits there and makes some
small little moves maybe just maybe some
poor moves that don't really have a
purpose
then what's going to happen is that
inner palm reaction is simply going to
move the king forward to its hiding
place and then the rooks will get
centralized and then
okay it becomes very very difficult for
white
to do anything all right well magnus
carlsen is
thinking we were talking about chess
books earlier and i want to mention to
you what my favorite chess book is
and obviously it's not a chess book with
many notations because i'm
not a great chess player but it is a
norwegian book called chess or
life by atlegran and what i love in that
chess book is that
um he he tries to find out what god's
chess rating would be and i think it's
an american scientist who
who figured out that god's chest rating
would be somewhere along 3
600. and so the quote in the book is so
magnus carlsen is 750 rating points away
from being god i think that's fantastic
i need to check that book out yeah oh
it's so much fun
chess or life and i guess it's a little
bit like that when you're a chess player
it's it just infects your whole life
yeah it's definitely affected our lives
maybe for everyone at home as well chess
is life
chess is life it is you get just so
obsessed with it just looking at these
64 squares and everything that is going
on there
64 squares but almost infinite
possibilities infinite moves i mean
i've been studying chess now for 25
years and i still have i still feel i'm
learning every single day
yeah absolutely we've played chess for
so many years and
every single game it's a it's a
different situation it's a different
position
and that's pretty that's pretty unique i
mean isn't there
more possibilities on the chessboard
than we have stars in the sky even
yeah yeah they said there's more than
atoms in the universe
just by the end of move one so white
makes a move black makes move there's
already 400 different positions
oh wow and it multiplies it infinitely
from there
it's incredible you can sort of
understand why magnus carlsen is taking
some time to think now i have no idea
what the number of possible moves here
is but i mean probably a lot that's
right that's right and
for those of you at home who think maybe
you know so many infinite possibilities
but
how do you understand it that's where
the beauty of chess comes in like you
all have
we all have different ideas we all have
different styles it's there's no right
or wrong answer sometimes and
yeah absolutely you just have to go
there and play and
and it does sound like mind-boggling
complex you know like you say all these
moves but you know that's that's really
not the fun in chess the fun is just to
sit down
with your friends jazz it out and you
know it just and if you want to get
better you want to start learning
then because there's some great websites
out there and if you want to start
there's some a fantastic one which is
called train magnus this is just for
beginners
and for basic things and you know even
has games where you land a plane on a
seven squares
i was playing that a few days ago
yes you just land planes and cents
squares and it gets faster and faster
and you know
stuff like that it really helps with
chess and it's a perfect game to teach
your child
exactly and i mean it's easier to learn
when you are a child like languages
a child's brain is more uh open to
learning chess than
than grown-ups not that grown-up
shouldn't start they should start
uncheckable
yes no i mean it is easier to learn as a
child but then as an adult you
understand it because um that's the one
of the beauties you have the
intelligence to actually
understand the strategies and you can go
oh yes
i understand that you'll you'll learn
well the child will probably take about
10 20 times or falling into the same
trap
before it realizes all right well after
a few minutes of thinking magnus made
his move it was a rook
move that's right a slightly mysterious
rook lift and actually it's a porn
sacrifice so and now we see napoli
actually has grabbed a pawn
and white rook swings the whole way
across the board um
i didn't even have that on my radar this
just shows magnus carson he's looking at
every side of the board there
that rook such a long range piece it
swung across
moved across six squares um very
impressive stuff that rook now
um on the right side it is targeting a
pawn just in front of it that pawn is
ganged up on by the white rook the white
queen
white is down upon right now but black's
queen is slightly offside on the left
on the left flank there very interesting
stuff by magnus very creative stuff
um the problem actually should be able
to hold the balance but magnus carlsen
trying a few different things trying to
surprise his opponent
and trying to get at him from every
angle yeah it's a difficult move to
react to because every all the action
was
on the left hand side of the board and
suddenly with the rook swinging over to
the right hand side you have to sit
there and
think about that one and then it's like
oh my king might be in danger and you
have to also remember
the computer and ourselves at home
know that the position is equal but i
can tell you napomniachi doesn't know
that
he's thinking oh is there danger here is
that something i must
think about everything and of course is
under the
pressure he is and his clock is ticking
he does still have more time on the
clock than magnus carlsen but
uh i mean it looks on his face and and
the way i've been talking about this
game so far david is that it's not very
comfortable
for him this position no that's right
and now we see he's kind of
wincing he's cringing he's not sure what
to even look for next
um it shows he's definitely not happy
also we mentioned the magnus effect
playing magazine golson sometimes i mean
i've been lucky i've played him several
times myself
you just see ghosts you think oh he
spotted everything you think oh that
looks scary
actually it's not that scary but it's
because it's magnus carson
that it becomes scary being 650 rating
points away from being god
i can't understand why you're seeing
ghosts with him there is a little trap
in the position
so for instance white is attacking that
pawn
on the right hand side of the board so
the natural instinct there is actually
to defend it so you defend it by
advancing a pawn
and this would be a horrible horrible
horrible move
because white would centralize the queen
just one square but i believe that's it
david
and suddenly the queen attacks the pawn
but also is threatening to penetrate the
position
so teamed with the rook you can imagine
the queen's rushing down
all the way and giving some very
unpleasant checks and we've seen it time
and time
again an undefended king is
in deadly peril that's right so
that would be a very greedy move trying
to defend this pawn now
um and it would backfire because black's
king would be so weak instead he tucks
his king away
allowing magnus to capture this pawn but
at least black's king now is still
protected by three pawns
he's still in the balance we see magnus
carson does grab his pawn back so he's
now restored
equality with the pawns he's restored
material equality and
okay very sensible thereby napoleon
actually putting his knight back in the
center of the board
knights are so good in the center this
one's still very much in the balance
we see the bar is roughly in the middle
but it's not clear at the moment it's
going to be a fight
whose position is easier to play whose
plans become more effective
um this one is going to heat up i think
magnus carson improving
another rook there um lining up his
queen and rook on the same line for
insensible stuff
the pony actually maybe with a slightly
weaker king so he is the one who has to
be
slightly careful here personally i
prefer white's position
despite the fact that maybe with best
play with perfect play
napoli actually can hold and napoleon
actually centralizing his queen
bringing it back towards the center
again very sensible chess
this is another tip for everyone at home
when in doubt you know especially if
your clock's ticking down
just look for your opponent's threats if
he has no immediate threats just improve
those pieces
make sure they defend each other make
sure they coordinate
um the worst possible thing is when all
of your pieces are undefended because
that's when the tricks
happen against you that's when things
start to go wrong so back there just
defending his night with his queen
yes beautiful isn't it just trying to
harmonize
the pieces together oh
okay we have a girl well very aggressive
move from magnus he loves this move
actually he has pushed
the pawn that we have nicknamed harry
because it stands on an h line
up two squares and well
and black has responded with mooring
kind
by advancing one of his pawns on the
left-hand side of the board
and that has been advanced two sides i'm
really liking this
both sides really playing very
uncompromisingly
that's right so maybe later they they're
getting ready for a pawn race
you can imagine if all the pieces start
disappearing it's about which pawns are
near the end of the board to make a new
queen to make a new piece
so both sides advancing pawns there not
necessarily recklessly
i think especially for black it makes
sense to push that pawn on the left side
because it is supported by a rook
i'm slightly more concerned about magnus
cast and he's pushing a pawn in front of
his king
but he has said in interviews he was
inspired by this
artificial intelligence program this ai
program alpha zero and alpha zero loves
pushing those pawns the corner of the
board
we do see a set of rooks being traded
now
and magnus he pushes that pawn even
further he's channeling
that ai program he's channeling alpha
zero yes and
i think he wants to come in with the
queen because that pawn is not going to
do any damage by itself
it's going to call for assistance and i
think the queen will answer
and will try to dash up the board
and then try and give a check very close
to black king
that's right if we bring up the board we
can see magnus carlsen he's got a sneaky
threat in mind it might take two minutes
uh it might take two moves it might take
three moves
but he's going to try and get at the
black king and it's all to do with using
that pawn
using his queen maybe using his bishop
all together and getting at that black
king
all right well jana pugnacci is thinking
he's under eight minutes on the clock
now
it i mean the the bar has been on
magnus's side
uh for big parties of the game it is not
very much in the center
do you think jana pognaci is seeing some
winning possibilities in this position
or is he only defending
for the time being i think he's
defending because his king is so
unsafe so his focus is just okay is my
king safe and if it is
then i will try to expand on the queen
side if it's not
it's i will take measures to protect it
so what we're seeing here is something
very reactionary
that's right and black is just pushing a
pawn at the side of the board there
actually that pawn cannot advance any
further it will just be captured by
one of white's pawns if it does continue
to advance but it is
stopping white from ever pushing forward
on that left flank it's just controlling
white's pawns on that side of the board
so
um this is very much just a battle black
is trying to stabilize the position
yeah yeah and we see the bar slightly
towards napoli actually slightly towards
black side there
maybe magnus's move is a bit slow just
pushing his bishop that bishop is still
not on a great square
it's still doing exactly the same job it
was doing on its start square last move
so yeah i think both sides are slightly
unsure
how to make progress how to start
advancing black retreats at night
um i'm not sure about that one again
that night was so beautiful in the
center board
but here it's just about maneuvering
waiting for the right moment
magnus castle he's going for the attack
though he's pushing
harry that pawn even further up the
board this is a temporary pawn sacrifice
i'm i mean i'm slightly concerned that
he's
um kind of playing by instinct here he's
not really getting into the position and
calculating that pawn could just be
taken potentially right now
because the bar does go over tiana pogba
to decide it does this move
it does definitely go up to the bar side
and the computer doesn't approve and
simply says
just take it off but uh yeah whether a
human will actually take that pawn off
because the thing is if you capture that
pawn
okay has done that okay we're expecting
magnus to come in with a queen and give
a check and the queen has checked and
the knight now
has blocked this check so wow
yeah so black has actually snapped off
of porn um the computer thought that was
by far the best move but for black we
saw in this position magnus carlsen he
can do anything here he can just improve
a piece
i would be looking to improve this
bishop uh this rook sorry or improve
this bishop
instead he pushes forward just that is a
pawn sacrifice
black snapped it off the computer's best
move as a human sometimes we want to
defend
sometimes we just think okay it's easier
to just keep our king nice and safe
behind these three pawns
but if your opponent is offering you a
pawn and you think
actually i can grab it and there's no
consequences then you might as well take
it and that's what the pontiac has done
this is the ambitious approach slightly
greedy but it's the ambitious approach
allowing a check and he's blocked with
his knight and knight is a king's best
friend
this knight blockading the queen check
defending everything magnus is just pawn
down right now he can recapture that
pawn
but then he would be walking into this
line of the rook
now his bishop could never move because
his queen would be attacked and white
would never be able to escape
from that line so i don't think magnus
is ever going to recapture that pawn
right now
he wouldn't even dream of it but if he
leaves that pawn on the board
will have an extra pawn black's knight a
great defender
i'm not sure what magnus carlsen has
planned it's a very mysterious move he
kind of rushed into it
will he regret that decision yeah
he may come to regret it you know it
might have been this desire to win that
might have clouded his judgment but i am
wondering whether you know i've
said time and time again magnus loves to
use all his pieces you know what he
won't be just content with just
attacking with the queen i think
he will try to involve a rook and uh
i don't think i agree with you david i
don't think he's going to be tempted
into capturing that pawn that's perhaps
something that can be captured
in some time if possible it's
located in phoenix face
he is he didn't take his poker face to
the chat
to the computer today i think he was
born without a poker face
uh some of them are really like magnus
carlsen is
he does have a poker face i think
sometimes sometimes yeah
well hikaro nakamura definitely does not
have one he's just giving away his
emotions all the time
yeah actually wow
i eat my words well
well we've been proven wrong on so many
occasions haven't we david
but uh in fairness they've been blunders
when uh we've been proven wrong
that's right and jana pogba actually did
well he looked surprised by that move
i'm shocked as well i mean magnus
carlsen his bishop and his queen are on
the same line as that black rook
his bishop can never move um i just
don't understand i mean
that paul okay he's won his pawn back so
he's no longer behind in material
he doesn't have to worry about later in
the game being a pawn down
but he's tied up i don't see what the
plan is long term black can even just
wait
how does white ever get that bishop back
into the game black can also even just
offer to trade queens
um black can just sit still um very
surprising napoli actually now
once he's recovered from the shock of
that last move he just has to
make sure he stays calm i don't think
there's an immediate way to win for
black
but um black has a very pleasant
position and magnus carlsen shaking his
head very slightly there i think he's
regretting
that last move yes i agree with you
david
it's very surprising move and you know
how you mentioned that your favorite
book
when you that when you were growing up
was uh the seven deadly chest-ins well
we actually have a tweet
from jonathan rowson he says it feels
like a lifetime ago since i wrote them
but i am so pleased to hear people still
talking about the seven deadly sins and
chess for cebras
and there's even better news here
because jonathan ralston says
i'll soon be doing workshop videos on
them for chess ball
which is amazing news because you know
jonathan ralston's books are just
fantastic so to have them in chessable
format
where you can just repeat them again and
again and improve you know improve your
just online it's just brilliant yeah
chess of all getting all the best
content these days i mean those
jonathan rosen like i mean firstly we're
honored to have a grandmaster watching
our show
um but yeah i mean he's one of the best
writers one of the most interesting
people he
i mean those books they got me through
very difficult time in my life i was on
a
exchange program in france and just
reading his seven deadly sins book
got me through that um yeah i can't wait
to check that out on chessable
meanwhile we have had a couple of moves
a bit of a surprising move by napoli
actually shuffling his queen across one
square
and magnus carlsen has attacked that
queen um in this position
i was expecting napoli actually to just
wait
i mean it's not clear what white's next
move is he could also even offer to
trade the queens off now
if he wants to play super safe because
he is in the lead today
instead he shuffled the queen across one
square um i'm not sure what the idea is
a very mysterious move and
magnus carson meets it by attacking this
queen the rook now gains time
it ends up on an open file there is a
possible trade here
um okay instead that queen just
sidesteps i thought maybe napoli
actually had some
tricky stuff in mind he could have gone
for safety instead he just shuffles his
queen across
the moves back with magnus carlsen the
question is how does he improve this
bishop now
how does he get this bishop out of the
line of the rook yeah but it's
certainly a kind of a little incentive
that mr prominently perhaps doesn't
quite know what he's doing because
magnus carlsen just got a free move and
you always get a little buzz when you
have those things happen
all right well uh chess 24 the host site
for this
tournament where we get all the chess
moves from they actually tweeted uh
asking is magnus carlsen on tilt david
is mike scrolls on tilt
good question um chess players i think
tilt it started from poco but
um chess now we've adopted that term it
means that once you've lost the game
things just start to spiral out of
control you can't readjust mentally
he's on tilt it all depends on this next
few moves though if he can turn the game
in his favor he'll be back to himself
he'll be relaxed
um and he'll be very confident that he
can progress
if the next few moves go against him i
think we might see magnus losing control
getting a bit emotional
that's the last thing you want sometimes
especially in these speed games you
can't get emotional
because otherwise you just lose control
you make mistakes because of that clock
because of panic
and you need to be calm but i have to
say magnus
is actually remarkable because i have
never seen him actually tilt so to speak
i see him lose and i then i immediately
see him come back and i'm like wow
and while other chess players they
really collapse and but magnus
seems to be of a different breed and i
just love love love love his next move
because he
has moved his rook of the board and i
just love it because
that rook could be dashing over to the
right hand side of the board
where it's going to spell a little bit
of
trouble for napomniachi all right well
do we see magnus carlsen i'm tilting
then
possibly i think the last two moves have
gone in his favor definitely napoli
actually
pretty much did what nakamura did in the
last game uh he lost
two moves he moved his queen across one
square
next move he just moved it yeah exactly
it it doesn't improve his position
meanwhile magnus as you mentioned you've
improved his rook he's going to swing
that rook across now
to the right side he's going to attack
that black knight it's all about
teamwork that
white's queen that we're gonna try to
get at that black knight together
um yeah i like what's happened um for
magnus and also napoli actually he had a
two three minute advantage
that's disappeared he's now one minute
behind on the clock
i think it's napoli actually who needs
to think about maybe playing safe now
he's one point up today remember
so if he wins i mean if he draws this
game he's still in
pole position uh he's still in prime
position to force some tie breaks at the
end of the day
um the problem actually he just has to
make sure he doesn't lose control yeah
and just
i i just love the body language as well
one of the great things about seeing is
that we get to see the aware of their
players
up close and personal on the on the
webcams you can see
magnus has his posture has improved and
he's
really into the flow and there we go we
have a very very committal move from the
pulmonary he has
pushed his pawn forward
and when you push pawns they have
consequences because they cannot go back
um oh yeah
and magnus has retreated his rook by one
square
and he's really determined to move that
rook to the right hand side of the board
he says
is that a humoristic move yes you can
see look at
he's looking at himself he's like yes
and deals with that my friend and like
patting his shoulder
good job i will keep
moving my rook until the end of time
chess players would definitely have that
in a monologue so i'm sure he's saying
yeah
all right what is the interlock
monologue for magnus right now or
before that move he's thinking you know
you're scared of me
you've you're trying to stop my threat
but i'm going to
keep keep dropping them on the board i'm
going to get at that king eventually
i'm imagining that in their monologue
now yeah no yeah i was thinking
you want to stop my wreck oh no
and yeah we do see janna ponnacci he's
played a move he didn't really want to
play he's moved his rook across one
square
but now white's bishop is free white
bishop is allowed to move
white's queen is no longer eyed up by
that black rook but also i have to say i
really really dislike that last move by
the part and well not the rig move but
the porn move by napoleon because
if you suddenly look at that white
bishop you can see that
all the squares around the black king
well
they're dark squares and white has a
dark squared bishop
and yeah absolutely dislike that because
suddenly the power of the bishop has
increased and for me
that spells problems that's right so
ivanka doesn't like this pawn push by
napoli actually he was scared
in this position of white swinging this
rook across attacking the knight so he
defended that square but
this is the move jovanka was laughing
about dropping the rook back saying i'm
going to get you
one way or another i'm going in behind
you
i'm going to get you get your get your
get you
you're going to join in david all right
um yeah we see um the problem actually
he
i've got that stuff in my head now um
actually he has shuffled his rook across
meaning that white's bishop is free to
move um last turn this bishop could not
move black's rook is eyeing up this
queen
now i would as white i would just think
about dropping this bishop back
and trying to break in the enemy camp
trying to get my queen into the game
um it feels like the momentum has
changed completely magnus carson is the
one with the time advantage and
the advantage on the board black's king
is the biggest factor of black's king
safe for now but as you may mention
those dark squares around it
oh yeah i completely forgot to get over
enthusiastic now when they got onto five
minutes
all right but they're going under two
minutes i'm getting so
excited wow this is getting interesting
definitely it's heating up it's heating
up and i think that's what magnus
carlsen wanted in this game he wanted to
surprise his opponent in the opening
keep some pieces on the board have the
slightly safer king
and maybe that will become a factor
towards the end of this game
he does need to speed up though he spent
a lot of time he spent over half his
time on this move
he's not going to decide the game he
just needs to needs to improve a piece
he needs to test his opponent he can't
drop under a minute because
he i mean if he just loses this next one
um the fight is right back on
exactly yeah no absolutely magnus needs
to hurry up and he
has moved the bishop one square
backwards
and napomniacci has sidestepped with the
rook
and is now attacking the queen so magnus
does need to move the queen
but uh yes oh okay that's right classy
classy retreat from magnus carlsen he's
retreated the queen all the way back
but uh look at the verruck and the queen
they are working so
nicely on the lines together that's
right a very sensible move there from
magnus carson
we normally don't approve of retreating
moves but
sometimes you need to find better lines
for your pieces especially those queens
and rooks
sometimes um you just need to set them
up a bit better a sneaky trap by napoli
actually now he's actually threatening
checkmate in two moves
yeah yes yes if we bring up the board we
see black's threat very sneaky he just
drops his queen back one square
and now he's lining up for a check on
this square
protected by the black rook um if white
is clumsy and
misses this and this will be a check the
king has to run and the king will be
trapped here um this would be checkmate
instead magnus carlsen stopping that by
trading the uh trading a power of rooks
off
um we see a pair of rocks have left the
board now he just dropped his rook
across on this side
i'm not sure about that decision um
black's offering a queen trade now
white's rejecting that queen trade white
needs to keep his queen on the board if
he's going to win this game
personally i always prefer queen and
knight against the queen and bishop
yes me too they're with a qui it's a
rick and bishop work better than rook
and knight and queen and knight work
better than queen and bishop
but yeah i didn't quite like that rick
trade to me i felt
jewish yes drawish
and you know we talked about it quite
often that you shouldn't exchange
pieces when one's king is unsafe and i
i feel that white king was fundamentally
still safer than black's king
yeah that's right i mean maybe he was
just feeling the tension it's very much
a safety first move there my magnus
obviously he wants to win this game but
maybe he's just thinking okay
it's more important not to lose yeah
absolutely
so how about magnus's harry pong
can i get dangerous wow actually now you
say it
that was something i was just gonna
bring up we do have a great chess player
uh i'll scale breathe is sitting um in
the control room and he tipped me
to ask you guys that's a great question
actually it was a bit of a name change
there it was gary the g pawn
on the g line and it became harry um
when it shifted across when it
when it captured a rook and now we see
that pawn advancing um you're reading
you're seeing the future
kaya um that pawn is running up the
board at the moment
that pawn uh white's pawn on the right
hand side it is stopped it can no longer
advance
uh further if it keeps advancing it will
get lost
black's king trying to stop that pawn
but that pawn
might just be used as an anchor for the
bishop white bishop is nicely protected
now
which frees up his queen white's queen
is going to try and
infiltrate the black camp maybe white's
queen can dash all the way up the board
to attack that black knight yeah
absolutely that is the most tempting
move to
whoosh with the queen all the way to the
top of the board and
start and he's done it he has done it so
the only danger there is for white
is that because the white king is
slightly unprotected and i'm
being using the british way of using
slightly
which means very okay
it just means that the king can be
vulnerable to a perpetual check that's
something that we saw in the
hikari the wesley hikaru nakamura game
so i'm gonna expect to see perhaps some
few checks on the board
that's right black has options here
black could give a check with his queen
or because his knight is attacked he
could just drop his king back to protect
that knight
um napoli actually though under a minute
about to go under 30 seconds
it's not an easy decision actually
giving check with the queen
probably would be a mistake possibly it
might be a mistake so
it's definitely easier for white to play
this position okay so
he has gone under 20 seconds and when
the clock starts ticking down
this is when a trouble happens and okay
he is
oh okay
queen has gone un protected but this is
very very passive
yeah never uns i mean that queen was so
nicely centralized never retreat your
queen unless you really have to
now white gave a check magnus class and
gave a check and he captured the pawn
oh look at the talking to himself yes
he knows he yes and uh the polish is one
[ __ ] suddenly all won
all the pawns on the left-hand side of
the board so he's two pawns up
and uh yes there's just no way forward
okay so
the night is the pogba actually is
centralizing the night in order to get
ready for some checks to cause some
trouble
and we should we've learned by a lesson
by now david we should never say never
yeah there's so many turnarounds and
with 30 29 seconds on the clock is yana
pogliati now
losing this game yes yeah he just forgot
about those pawns on the left side of
the board
he retreated his queen his queen was
protecting those pawns he retreated it
allowing magnus to capture those two
magnus is two pawns ahead magnus also
has the safer king
he's got everything protected now all
magnus needs to do is make sure he
doesn't
make the same mistake that wesley so
made doesn't allow anything seven
seconds
oh he made his move oh that's a
depressing one to have to play black's
queen dropping into the corner there
um i i'm very surprised about that last
move
i don't really understand what the
queen's doing in the corner of the board
and napoli actually shaking his head he
knows he that one move he let it slip
um the computer said it was equal but
it's just because white's position was
easier to play white had the safer king
and now two pawns ahead magnus carson if
he doesn't win this one
then we'll know he's badly out of form
yes and after
the time situation magnus has one minute
and 12 seconds
to napolita's 18 seconds so everything
in his favor
yeah that's right all he needs to do is
make sure his king is safe and then
slowly start advancing those pawns on
the left side he has done
he is pushing those pawns they want to
get okay and
napoleon is using his king as an
attacker i'm not quite sure what that is
all about
that's right i think uh magnus carson
will just ignore that last move by
napoli actually
black's king is always going to be weak
there's no point to go for that king
right now
magnus has done the hard work he just
needs to keep things simple
magnus carson he's a genius at doing
this keeping things simple
killing his opponent's threats killing
his opponent's dreams
blacks retreated a king there magnus
will soon
continue exactly
do you think we will see three queens on
the board in this game now
i hope so i hope so for your sake yeah i
know i mean i
see it maybe four queens white has two
pawns on that left side
which could just run up and uh become a
lady so
yeah um it's looking very hopeless for
napoli actually there's just no way to
even get close to saving this game
there's no way to even check the white
king right now
he's bringing his queen across yes but
it's all pretty hopeless
um is there something is that a blunder
i think white couldn't okay white can
threaten the okay he threatens the black
knight
black's queen jumps across and gives
check white is just going to
move out the way of that one or block
that check with his bishop and the
pontiac
shaking his head yep and he's been very
very careful with where he puts his king
because the knight is such a such a
crafty piece you always have to be aware
of where it can move to and
magnus is now on the attack and i expect
him to
perhaps come forward with his queen and
start infiltrating the position yep he's
there
that's right so white bring just
bringing that queen slowly towards the
black
yeah and just know the kind of
only actually and uh i think the game
will be over
yes it is it is over wow
he looked so strong and then he does
lose the second game it is
1-1 on the scoresheet and well he
definitely does still have possibilities
to
tie the semi-final match uh but it's
going to get harder for
no pogchi now yes he has to he has to
win
at least one more game and definitely
not drop if he drops a point that's it
game over his match well game seven
match
and uh it'd be magnus he goes through to
the final because
um napolita needs to win all right well
there is still one game going on in this
round
two of the semi-final matches wesley so
won the first game well then he dropped
the first game against
hikar nakamura we won yesterday they are
playing i'm just looking at the bar it
says
winning for wesley so do you agree david
yes that's right the first thing i do in
every position is just do a bit of
counting
and here wesley so as an extra pawn more
importantly wesley sews pieces they're
nicely coordinated white is on the
defensive here
um a bit of a strange move there by
wesley so just retreating his bishop
um we've actually seen a repeat of the
position wesley so
completely winning here surely he won't
drop his bishop back and repeat the
position for a third time
wesley under a minute though here if
wesley if he
retreats his bishop if he brings it back
uh two squares along the diagonal
that'll be the third time we reach this
position and the game will be a draw
we've seen wesley do this in winning
positions before either just
get nervous and guide the game towards
the draw or just play safety first chess
but all he needs to do is maybe start
some trades
capture that white knight with his
bishop if black captures that knight
with the bishop he's removing one of
white's defenders
i think white's army white's just going
to be overwhelmed he's done it he's done
it he's done it david
he is taking the night and yeah takara
in trouble and uh he's bashing out the
moves the rook
takes the knight and now the queen has
given a check
to the king king can either move or the
check can be blocked and has been
blocked by the rook
and wesley just grabbing those pawns
he has taken one pawn and it's up to
hikaru now
to set those tricks and traps he's so
good at doing this
that's right we saw it in the first game
well uh wesley so blundered in a
completely winning position in the first
game
it ended in a draw um is that what he
car needs to hope for in this game as
well now
he needs a miracle wesley has a couple
of winning moves here he is two pawns
ahead
also black still has the safer king
black has pawns around his king
white's knight has just dropped back to
attack the black rook but
black can actually ignore it black can
trade rooks here he can use his rook to
capture white's rook um
white is just okay instead he just drops
back with his rook a very safe solid
move
wesley not in a rush he's got 20 seconds
so he's just trying to gain
you do gain 10 seconds after every move
he's just trying to gain time on the
clock
um here white's attacking one of the
black rooks with his knight that black
rook
will move oh instead he's dropped his
knight back
very flashy move there oh
but at the bar david um i'm just trying
to work out what's happened
white has okay maybe wesley so he's
missed something here he tried to
play a flashy move with 20 seconds on
the clock you should never do this
never complicate things keep things
simple instead he's allowed white to
capture a rook with his knight was
he so currently a rook down now 10
seconds
he's captured a white rook with his
knight but
i think oh look at it look at it he's
realizing he blundered again
again yes white can start
counter-attacking now i can give a check
with his knight
where i can jump right into black's camp
here
um onto the back rank i would just give
that check as hikaru nakamura and then
think what to do next
nakamura he's got so much time for him
one and a half minutes he can play five
games in that time
we see as well the computer confirms and
he's done it
okay and now he has attacked the knights
he attacked the rook with his knight and
the pressure
is on on wesley remember he only has 17
seconds
left on the clock and now the position
is very
very sharp because white has the
potential
for rook to come in and deliver check
okay so that is why wesley
has played rook taking
he's played his rook one move one square
and now the rooks
will be traded off that's right so white
has an opportunity now to draw the game
immediately
wesley so completely panicked there
um he just uh now white can trade the
rooks from the board
white can also grab the black knight
potentially after that
i think hikaru nakamura he's not happy
with the draw anymore he wants to win
he knows that wesley's been playing very
badly the last few moves he knows
wesley's completely blown it yeah maybe
wesley can't recover so hikaru he's
going for blood
position should be a draw i think white
has nothing better than
maybe going for a perpetual check just
trying to force a repetition of moves
but hikaru nakamura yeah is a fighter i
think we're going to see it where he's
captured the knight and now wesley has
to take as many pawns as possible
but the queen and knight work so well
together
that's right so the current position
black is down at night but he does have
three pawns for that night and that's
roughly
equal so knight is worth normally the
same as three pawns
here is just a question of whose king is
weaker and unfortunately for nakamura i
don't think he has enough
pieces left to checkmate the black king
there's no way to immediately checkmate
and if he can't checkmate immediately
black is the one who'll start to give
lots of checks with his queen
yeah we see nakamura giving a check now
giving another check um wesley so
retreating his king to the corner
nakamura he's going to be looking for a
way to set a trap now
he's got to try and find a trick to
check mate wesley if he draws this game
he'll still be happy he'll still be
relieved that he's even in this match
after having such a bad position but it
might not be enough
no it's probably not enough is it
because the white king is so
exposed because you want that you want
to have that ability
to still keep the king trapped and
introduce the knight into the attack but
if you do that
then this white king is just so exposed
and so unprotected
that black can probably give a whole
load of checks for the queen and
white will never ever be able to escape
those yeah we saw
nakamura as well he was gesturing with
his hand he was just trying to count you
could see him counting along with his
hand he's trying to see
how he can get at that black king he's
trying to see
which checks are the most dangerous now
it's very very important okay and wesley
has played it he had to move
his king to that square because
otherwise
the knight would come in with a very
deadly check and now
hikaru has checked and wesley retreats
his king
that's right so unfortunately for white
he just doesn't have time to bring his
knight into the game
white could try and improve his night
trying to set up a checkmate but then
black would start giving lots of checks
mm-hmm that is why wesley he had to put
his king in the corner he couldn't allow
well we had well he has grabbed a pawn
whoa we can see that he has he wants
more just like you said
can he kara nakamura fight for a win in
this game white is the only one who can
win nakamura is the only one who can win
wesley has to be careful that he gives
the right checks
oh look the bar we see maybe he gave the
wrong check um
it's not clear yet i think he's still
okay and the bar zoomed back towards the
middle yeah the computer needed a second
thing there
that's right so wesley though the one
thing he can't do is allow white to
escape the checks
he needs to find the right way to check
and that's not easy with 30 seconds on
the clock
exactly nakamura doing a very clever
thing oh okay wesley he's not given a
check
he's just captured a pawn how cool is
that i would be terrified to allow
my opponent to start checking me with
the queen um
i mean maybe that's just a genius move
by wesley he sees that there's no way
for white to checkmate and nakamura he
just pulls up his
sleeves and he's ready to fight in the
end of this game
he definitely needs to come back with a
win
and he played his queen that's right
yeah and again
well again wesley has problems where is
he going to put the king
which square so he has chosen to move
his king up one ball
one square and now the queen has given
check and
again does wesley so make a dash for it
with his king and he has
the king is now out that's right so
wesley
was too scared to stay in the corner
with his king there so now he's just
running forward
maybe he'll keep stepping up the board
maybe he'll drop back now with the king
personally i'd find it so difficult to
choose um wesley so advancing with his
king there
i was white continuing to give checks
now again he has to be very careful
where he puts his king because you do
not want to allow the knight
to give check at the same time
let the king be trapped so those are the
two things you're looking for trapping
the king and introducing the knight
into the game with a check and uh
queen gives check and the king runs to
the edge of the board
and the sad thing for hikaru is that if
the queens were going to be traded
then there's no it's yes
well and we see on wesley so he's not
very happy he knows he
plundered a winning position again
exactly the match could have been over
by now right yeah
yeah that's right and actually he's
still playing with fire wesley so
um he's holding the draw at the moment
but he is the one who has to be careful
still
um nakamura close but not quite close
enough to checkmating that black king
he's still trying to set traps he's
hoping that wesley puts his king on the
wrong square
every turn he's hoping wesley gets
nervous again but
it looks like maybe black is safe now
white just needs another pawn on the
board he needs that knight a bit more
centralized in order to win this game
he just won't have enough time to do
that great defense by wesley so but
yeah he'll be looking back with regret
he could have been two nil up now if
wesley had won that last game and won
this game the match would actually be
over immediately
yep um yeah i think we will see a draw
shortly but nakamura still trying he is
a fighter
little time on the clock as well though
under 40 seconds for a car now but
obviously
not so many pieces on the board so it
should be possible to well at least not
lose it for hikaru here
yes i don't think hikaru will lose it um
he just
has he's just desperately trying to
introduce that kind of
hoping that wesley goes to the wrong
square or whether he can get his
knight into with a check and not let the
black king
dash for freedom that's right and we see
black retreating his king there if he'd
brought it forward
um one square he would have actually
lost so um
yeah very sensible play by wesley so
nakamura
maybe if he had three four minutes on
the clock he could think about how to
try and keep some tension in this game
how to keep trying to set those traps
hoping that wesley walks into one of
them but i think
now the clock situation has changed
around nakamura under 10 seconds
against wesley so's one minute and
not giving checks yeah he's trying he's
trying hard so
he has retreated the queen it's not a
check as david pointed out
so again this is i think this is a wise
strategy because
there is still a lot of danger black
could easily go wrong
and we have to remember that's a very
crafty pieces with one
fork which which is a check which um
can attack two pieces at once the game
would be over okay so
if hikaru desperately trying with a
queen check king steps backwards
that's right now we've seen so many
checks in this game
i'm wondering if we get to move 100
because there'll be so many checks
um white continuing to check with the
queen but
there's just no hope here to win this
game white's knight's still not quite in
the game
and white king very open white's king
vulnerable to as many checks as wesley
wants to give
um yeah this one should still be a draw
but still some tension and i just love
the fact that nakamura is fighting he's
got
he's got about 15 seconds on the clock
but he's still fighting he's still
pressing for that win and that's one tip
for everyone at home
as long as there's still life in the
position you might as well play
yes it might go wrong he's moved his
knight tonight has given check
but the king wasn't trapped so the king
has made his bid for freedom
and what i really like about wesley's
move is that he actually put his queen
on a square that is defended by a pawn
so there's not going to be any
traps there that's right and wesley
advancing with his king now
his king's still quite safe the queen
and knight can't quite combine to trap
that black king
um white does capture a pawn though
wesley shaking his head slightly i don't
think that changes
the evaluation of the position i think
the players have actually agreed a draw
yeah yeah and wesley so did not look too
happy about that it must feel terrible
to blunder
uh two winning positions in a row yeah
absolutely you know he was completely
winning and he just made a careless slip
and that was it
hikaru got away and it's not very
pleasant after pushing the whole
whole game that suddenly you're the one
defending and you're the one having to
navigate all the danger that's not great
news
but still two games left still two games
left we see players still sitting there
hikaru nakamura feeling
so so lucky he is still in the fight
here
yeah i think he's 50 50 now i mean the
momentum's on his side he saved two
completely lost positions
it feels like he's he's used up all of
his nine lives but now it's his time to
pounce
um if he can win one of these games
wesley so i hope it's going to be
difficult
to recover and this is what it looks
like after two games have finished in
round two of
semi-finals magnus cross now won the
second game after losing the first one
in
uh against gianna pogniacci the score is
one
one and if magnus carlsen wins this next
game
then it will be over he will be the
winner of the semi-final match
um and hikaru nakamura oh
this is wesley so realizing he blunders
terribly a winning position for the
second time in a row oh
he is very disappointed and uh
hikaru nakamura well he doesn't look too
happy but
he he did get quite lucky in that game
didn't he yeah i think hikaru he was
never actually winning but at the end
of course after that huge turnaround
after saving a lost position he did want
to push the whole way and get that point
wesley defended well though at the end
so hikaru i think he's just more
frustrated with the way he's playing
so they have one point each chikara
nakamura and wesley so before they
play their next game we're heading into
magnus carlsen versus yana pognaci
third game if magnus wins the semi-final
will be over
he is heading to the final jana
pognaccia needs at least half a point
here
yes he needs at least that he does need
at least half a point
preferably a victory would be good but
uh we'll see what happens
you can see magnus is in this glow the
momentum is
is is on his side because of course he
just come
back from a victory that's right and we
can hear the pings i think play
pieces have been moved but the board
will catch up in a moment
um yeah i think napoli actually he's not
the kind of player who'll play it safe
he will throw everything at magnus
carson
also this is his last game with the
white pieces and with white that's
by far his best chance he knows if he
leaves it
with the black pieces magnus will just
be able to shut that game down
i think this is last chance saloon for
nepali actually all right we are having
some technical issues getting the moves
out on the board we heard
a lot of uh ding-ding-dings which means
there has been a lot of moves actually
already nine from each player um what
are you guessing
oh we don't have to guess oh we have it
here
that's right and we have seen an opening
um we won't go back to it but this
is another spanish opening um on the
board so the spanish
we see um it is it is kind of defined by
this last move by white
uh very standard play both sides opening
with their kings pawns and once white
develops the bishop
attacking this knight we call this the
spanish opening uh
white puts pressure on the black center
from the side he's going to use this
bishop to put
pressure he's going to try and build his
own pawn center
he's just going to try and take over as
much territory as possible and we see
the next few moves
a bit later on if we catch up with the
game now black is the one trying to take
central control black has pushed his
pawn forward using both of his pawns to
control some very important squares
and he's actually offered a trade of
bishops so um
black offers to trade these bishops here
white's beautiful bishop keeping an eye
along this diagonal
is going to leave the board that's going
to trade it off now white
i mean a very rare move i think from
napoli actually trying to bring his
knights
closer to the black king um that night
has been traded off if we catch up with
game position
very controversial stuff napoli actually
i've actually seen him have something
very similar to this before
he's um he's given up his knight for a
pawn
uh for a bishop sorry but he's allowed
his opponent
to take control of the center magnus
carson look at these pawns four
super strong pawns in the center here um
but white does have this nice bishop
maybe lining up with the black king
later on so both sides
pursuing completely different strategies
which will be stronger black's pawns
along that line or white pieces long
term
well knowing he has to win at least one
of the two final
games can we see from jan pognatis play
her with white pieces that he is
going for blood as we call it well
no surprisingly my answer to that
because
it is a very risky strategy because well
look at those
pawns that black has in the center you
know it's a beautiful wall of pawns and
i personally i
love my space and i love the possibility
of advancing pawns and taking
as much area as possible and uh
nepalniacci has gone for very very risky
strategy where he's going to put
pressure on those pawns
and perhaps go for a kingside attack but
uh
it doesn't look necessarily that
aggressive to me
i don't know i slightly disagree ivanka
i think this is very
um a very imbalanced position i think
the white has great chances now he
brings his queen forward he's attacking
black's pawns from the side with his
queen um i think okay
yes black does have these beautiful
pawns but white has his advantages as
well white has two bishops
later if those pawns disappear if the
position opens up
that will favor white also with this
queen advance it's easier for white to
bring his pieces towards the right side
of the board towards the black king
than it is for black to advance those
pawns so actually
in the balance i'd say um both sides
have their chances but
it shows napoleon he's he's not going
for something like he did yesterday he's
not shutting the game down
and allowing a quick draw he's keeping
tension and now he's jumped forward with
his bishop
attacking the black knight um i like
what he's done
i think it will give give him some
chances a bit later
he knows this is his opportunity yeah
he's putting pressure on that santa
he because the threat is to take the
knight one of the things you do is when
your opponent controls the center you
would start
attacking the defenders of that center
so he's just done that by
by with that bishop move because now
that bishop is attacking the knight
and if the knight goes away then the the
pawn center is
very very weak and we do see magnus with
sometimes his head is in his hand here
is this
magnus trying to memorize something
i think their in novel territory i think
this is all new
so um yeah magnus he's been playing this
type of opening as black pretty much his
whole life so
he might have not seen this exact
position before but he'll have seen
something similar so it's more about
maybe trying to recognize some patterns
um trying to gather some ideas that he's
seen in similar positions before and
seeing which ones work
in this exact occasion so
lots of choice here for black he does
need to worry about his pawns though
they might
become weak if he doesn't defend them so
this is great stuff so we've got david
liking the pieces me liking the pawn
correct between you guys too now yeah
you're backing magnus though that's not
fair
all right well those are definitely
interesting those four black
pawns there almost look like you know
like in high school a gang of
girls just you know the most popular
girls in school working towards you
that's right no i really do adore pawns
and if i can push them forward i
i feel that like you said they're quite
threatening
yeah exactly like those four girls in
high school would be
exactly you know they're just forming a
wall and no you're not going to push
through
because i mean if magnus can make that
light square bishop that is on the left
hand side of the board for white
just stay on that square for a long time
well basically napoleon actually is a
piece down and those pawns are doing an
excellent job so the pressure is on
if magnus can maintain that wall then
brilliant stuff
if he can't then he's in trouble
that's right maybe we can bring the
board up to illustrate the point ivanka
makes about that bishop
it's actually all a fight about this
bishop right now if this bishop can't
break past these two pawns
then white is essentially playing
without that piece for the rest of the
game
if black can maintain these three pawns
completely blocking in this bishop
then black will be very happy and we see
a
controversial move by magnus carson
pushing pawn forward that's a pawn
sacrifice
as far as i can tell um actually maybe
not maybe magnus carson he's just trying
to
shut things down in the center white has
captured a pawn we'll see
um we'll see leonardo pognachi's
reaction a pawn has been traded from the
center of the board
at first i thought this was a sacrifice
maybe what could capture this pawn but
this would be a huge mistake
black could just capture the knight now
there's a bit of tension with these
bishops
once the bishops disappear black defends
the knight at the end of the line so
very interesting stuff the main thing we
notice though is white's bishop here
is just blocked out the game maybe a
very clever idea there by max carson
all right we see the bar shifting over
to magnus carlson's side we see
his girl gang black pawns they've been
they've been just the group has been
shaken up
they're not uh standing strong together
anymore as the annapolis
webcam is uh turned off maybe he's
having internet
connection problems that's right we saw
we heard it with magnus carson yesterday
at some point his browser just closed
and he had to race to try and get back
in that game cost him a couple of
minutes on the clock
and what are the rules if the players
lose their connection
well they have 30 seconds to disconnect
and he is back he is back
yes but they have 30 seconds to resume
their connection and if they happen to
have less than 30 seconds on their clock
then too bad you lose on time
but uh if they have more time and say
for instance they don't manage to
to resume their connection within 30
seconds then
the game is actually paused and uh the
the game will resume when the player
officially connects back on
all right well he was if if he lost
connection then he was on magnus
carlsen's time
he has been thinking um for a minute or
so on his next move
uh what can he do now david i think
he'll just be
trying to get the rest of his pieces
into the game we've talked about rooks a
few times
now black's last move a very nice move
he's just brought his queen forward
black's rooks are now collected on the
same line there you always want to
connect your rooks it just adds a bit
more flexibility it adds extra
protection
for later on um black
he needs to as well as mobilize those
rooks he needs to bring his knight off
the edge of the board we see
black's knight on the left side there um
it needs to get its
self back towards the center we've
mentioned this in the past we like our
rhymes here
and knights on the rim are dim knights
on the edge full of that
yeah that's my one that's the old one um
so yeah as long as magnus carlsen can
mobilize the rest of his pieces he's
just gonna hope that that bishop we've
talked about that [ __ ]
that white bishop on the edge there it's
just gonna be blocked in
um it's all a battle about whether that
bishop jumps back into life a bit later
on meanwhile
napoli actually bring a rook into the
center for a sensible move there
targeting one of black's pawns uh this
one is very much in the balance i think
it will work
the course of the game the site will be
pressing for the advantage it's all
going to be decided in the next
few moves imagine if this one ends up
in the draw and we come to like game
four and we
know jana pogniacci if he doesn't win it
he's out
um i almost hope that will happen
yeah i mean i i really like tie breaks
so i'm not so sad if
um if magnus loses this match i know
yeah we would love some tiebreakers too
exactly and just imagine the fireworks i
mean that would just be brilliant
but uh yeah definitely i mean i really
love the story the sporting story is
having to come back
and napoli actually has done it before
yeah he did it in the quarterfinals
it would be absolutely amazing if he
could do it again and against the world
champion yeah magnus looks like looks
like he's barely awake at the moment
actually
just trying to refocus and trying to get
back his rhythm
he is a few minutes behind on the clock
he also does have a pawn under attack
so magnus carlsen yeah he definitely
needs to be accurate to make sure that
that comeback you guys were talking
about that it doesn't happen
uh the momentum is all about momentum in
these one-to-one
um head-on-head clashes so
magnus personally i would just improve
one of those rooks right now for magnus
or i would bring that knight on the edge
of the board
that left hand side of what i'd bring
that back towards the center i would
sacrifice my pawn in the middle
because i think it's all about pieces at
the moment rather than those spawns
and we talked so much about psychology
today with the
the psychology for any player facing
magnus carlsen and how they
sometimes play less accurately because
they're seeing ghosts as he said david
but
for magnus playing jana pognachi a
player he lost
many games to in classical chess um
do you think magnus sometimes also
sort of plays his opponent not just the
board
definitely we saw that in his
quarterfinal against anish giri he
admitted afterwards he said
i know how he thinks um he offered a
queen trade um when it would have
not been a good idea for anish and anish
went for it because that's just his
style
so magnus he knows napolita's style he
knows his strengths his weaknesses
he's had historically he's had a
difficult time against him but that
trend is slowly turning in magnus's
favor
um i think magnus is definitely the
master of that psychology
meanwhile napoli actually i think he's
just trying to play quick because he's
not thinking about the opponent and that
last move very mysterious move
personally i'm shocked but maybe it's a
genius move what do you think
yeah i'm not liking it i mean it's just
admitting defeat
defeats to me anyway it's saying okay
well that bishop is not going to go
out on that diagonal so i'm going to
re-route it
and once i move my knight and once more
i move my pawn
then it will finally come back to life
not necessarily the move that i would
have chosen because
it's a backward move and i feel that the
position warrants
white actually doing something more
that's right it's a retreat
um an unnecessary retreat maybe if we
bring up the board just to show why
we're
so kind of down about that move in a way
um white had a decent position white
could think about a lot of things
maybe just trying to improve this rook
here which is a bit trapped not doing
anything or i could improve these rooks
instead
we'll catch up with a position in a
moment white just retreated this bishop
this bishop is completely blocked by its
own pawn it needs to move
white needs to move this knight and then
move this pawn for this bishop to ever
have any life in the game whatsoever
this bishop completely blocked it's as
if white's playing without a piece
therefore magnus says okay i'm just
going to improve one of my own pieces a
rook on an open line
always a good idea i like the last
couple of moves for magnus
in the meantime though napoli actually
grabbing a pawn he's one opponent in the
sense of the board here
let's see how this one turns out he's
traded pieces and this knight has
captured
in the middle defended by this round and
magnus has retaliated and
grabbed a pawn on the left-hand side of
the board that
bishop it's a little bit of a risky
foray into that side of the board
because i would say the action is
happening exclusively in the center or
on the right hand side because you know
you have the
white queen lined up to a certain square
the knight could mobilize over there
and the sleeping bishop that is
currently for white
that is on the left-hand side of the
board could
get into the action so i would say it's
slightly risky
that's right i mean the speed with which
magnus carson took that decision it's
very impressive
um i would have sat there doubting
myself for four or five minutes thinking
actually with black do i want to push my
bishop all the way across
napoli actually he's going for the
attack now he's making the most of the
fact that black's bishop has just left
that square
he's pushed his pawn forward he's trying
to open up that bishop we've talked
about that bishop so much in this game
um he's trying to open up that diagonal
for it by hook by crook
even at the cost of a few pawns if we
bring up the board we can see
why ivanka and i we're so excited about
that last move
um it's all about this white bishop
right now white could try and activate
that bishop by pushing a pawn forward
maybe this bishop will become more
powerful along this diagonal but first
napoleon actually he's pushed a pawn
forward if this pawn is taken i think
that would be a huge mistake
um white could just push this pawn
forward now and look at this bishop
suddenly it's come to life
white just needs to move the knight out
the way and suddenly white will be
giving checkmate a huge attack
along this diagonal the queen and the
bishop teamwork lining up on that one
pawn
so napoli actually he has to try and
keep this position blocked but it's not
easy anymore
how do you stop this bishop from
entering the game it's a dead piece
right now but later it might become the
most important one
yeah absolutely uh absolutely worried i
mean i
i really dislike allowing those kind of
porn moves so
close to the board oh i think
i think i think the black king will have
to hide in plain sight
[Laughter]
which is something that we've actually
seen it do a few times
that's right so black he can't touch the
pawns in front of his king either
there's
there is a trap um i think black has to
just
hope for the best now maybe he needs to
bring his queen into the game
um black's bishop out there on the on
the left side it just looks offside
it looks it's out in siberia somewhere
while the
the action is happening elsewhere um i
really like
white's position right now magnus cast
is five minutes behind on the clock as
well
he's the one who needs to be accurate
the computer still says it's in control
black is still fine
but it's for a human it's very difficult
when you're being attacked
and when you only have one or two moves
maybe to survive yeah it's very very
difficult to play with such an unsafe
king
and like you say that bishop that's for
white the white bishop
on the left-hand side of the board it
looks so dead but
give me one move and it will be out
there and
joining in the attack with the queen and
the knight
all right we do have actually some drama
in in the other semi-final match up
against wesley so and hikaru nakamura
started playing their game
a minute ago and it is already a draw
so they have decided that they will go
all in in round four hikaru nakamura
has to win in the fourth game if he
wants to take his two tie breaks
i have no idea what happened in that
game but they didn't play many moves
i'm shocked they've actually repeated
pretty much the exact game they've had
twice before
in previous tournaments so nakamura with
black he's allowed wesley so to force a
draw
with white wesley so said okay i'm
i don't care about the white pieces i'm
just going to get one game closer to the
goal of qualifying for the final but
that might rebound if nakamura wins with
white next
it's like time breaks and you know
hikaru has been so
charmed these last few games he has
really gotten away with murder
yeah yeah all right well we will
definitely keep an eye on what is
happening hopefully we actually uh
make it to that fourth game between
those two starting in
14 minutes or so um as we do
follow the third game between magnus
carlsen and diana
the score is one one after two games
niana pognati
he um he needs points he needs points
badly
and that's why magnus carlsen is
offering a trade of queens right now
this is all psychology uh magnus he's
trying to keep his king safe he's
worried about his
he's worried about his king safety we've
seen this so many occasions
when he's being attacked he trades
queens and he survives because he's a
master in the end game
and um jana pogba actually he needs to
keep the queens on the board
dodge that queen exchange yes never
trade those queens
definitely he needs to start looking at
that king with the queen
and coming forward and because
if napoli actually gets that bishop in
to get into the play and the knight into
play then
it will be absolutely deadly attack
because three is the magic number for
attackers
yeah that's right and there we see
stockfish the computer it does
suggest three white moves there all of
white's three best moves
are keeping the queens on the board it
would be a huge mistake to trade the
queens right now
um the computer just wants to advance
white's queen forward either one step
or two steps keeping the tension keeping
the potential
attacking uh yeah just keeping a
potential attack ready
um i do think magnus carson he's praying
to god right now he's
he's kind of flinching he's hoping
beyond hope that the queens disappear
critical moment in this game i think
napolniacci
needs to make a quick decision either
way
and look at the intense thinking
on both sides here
but i'm really puzzled by napomnaci's
pause because
to me it's very obvious you don't
exchange queens you're attacking
black's king is unsafe it's everything
we've gone through so it's very natural
that
okay we step forward with the queen and
we start inching our way forward
and you know white's porn that's there
all the way
up in black's camp on the right hand
side of the board it's
just so beautiful i mean and that's a
kind of
signal as well that if possible you can
try and attack on the dark squares
so what is napoli actually waiting for
that's right a three-minute function
right now and it's
it must be what we talked about earlier
this magnus carlsen effect
i think anyone else in the world i know
if napoli actually i've played him so
many times if he was playing me he would
show me no respect he would keep the
queens on the board and try and
checkmate me
but because it's magnus carlsen he's
pausing and
these three minutes that he's been
spending maybe he'll look back and think
actually i could have played a move
immediately could have put magnus back
under pressure on the clock
could put the ball back in his court
magnus as well frowning slightly maybe
he's surprised that the pontiac is still
pausing
yeah but every second that he pauses
that he gives magnus some
hope um i certainly would be encouraged
by the fact that my opponent is thinking
for a long time
and uh yeah we'll get inspired that's
right and ivanka mentioned this pawn
it's all about this pawn white going for
the attack
therefore i would keep the queens on the
board i would not trade along this
diagonal i would advance my queen
forward either one step or two steps
um for example just here now there's no
queen trade if black gets uncomfortable
if that moves upon in front of his king
now we would see this is a huge mistake
white could jump in
and teamwork again this pawn this queen
they're both lining up on the same
square
one is going to drop the queen into that
square next move
trapping the black king and this would
be checkmate so
there's already some huge problems for
magnus carson
i mean it's actually quite hard to stop
that type of idea
just why is napoli actually thinking i
don't understand four and a half minutes
right now
that's a huge time investment yeah
absolutely
and incidentally that checkmate had a
name
i'm going to tell it to you lolly lolly
lolly yeah why on earth is
that jack makeup after a historical
figure oh
yeah mr lolly who is mr lolly well
you're putting me on the spot now oh
sorry i remember
was it a chess player grandmaster yeah
yeah some historical figure
okay yeah i'm googling mr lolly right
now
it's about with a i at the end okay
while you google mr lolly
uh mr lollipop uh i think actually if
white were to advance the queen maybe
just trying to get inside napolita's
mind
if white were to advance the queen keep
the queens on the board i think black i
think napoli is worried about a
sacrifice
magnus carson would sacrifice his rook
for that knight in the middle of the
board there
just in order to keep his king safe
maybe napoleon is just trying to work
out the consequences there but either
way
he's lost all of his time advantage he
had a huge advantage on the clock there
and i think
that just shows the nerves are starting
to set in yes
but he has to take that risk he means he
cannot
he he just cannot swap off queens that
is just non-negotiable so just keep the
queens on
and then uh if the sacrifice comes then
accept that and then play
so jamba jam
battista lolly was an italian chess
player
born in 1698 and
the checkmate pattern lollies made in
walls in phillip infiltrating the
opponent's fianchetto position using
pawn and queen that's it and we saw it
there
that's right uh and i quoted uh
wikipedia i guess i have to say that
[Laughter]
a pretty good source it is yes um so
that
that lolly mate is what um
he's going for the idea immediately and
we are going to expect that magnus
pushes that pawn
and uh now come on start moving the
pieces forward
that's right so napoli actually he has
to get his queen into that square
he has to go for lolly's mate um he if
he's able to get his queens that or even
close to that square
magnus carson is going to have to
sacrifice material just to postpone the
checkmate
um there we see the queen has washed
across just a couple of squares oh but
look at the bar
yeah i don't like that move personally i
think maybe there was a better way to
try and do that i would have tried to
block off black's bishop potentially yes
blocking off the back bishop looks
amazing
that's right so i think right now maybe
magnus carson has a strong move he needs
to get rid of that white pawn
if we bring up the board we can see
white's idea napoli actually
napoli actually's idea if you had one
move here with white white is winning
the queen would jump in and give
checkmates to the black king
lolly's mate as we've seen earlier um
instead i think napoli actually
maybe has missed that if black tries to
attack this pawn this pawn is not going
to survive any longer
the bishop is just going to come back
and win this pawn with the help of the
black queen
um it's still the computer might say
that black is winning but
we've seen a couple of moves it's still
in the balance i think it's not easy for
a human to play this position
as either color it's very much in the
balance and there we see the bar uh
magnus carson he's actually sacrificed a
rook for a knight
just to get rid of that white pawn
exactly yeah and
wow i must admit i don't
like the move that we've just seen on
the board by unapomniachi where he has
advanced his pawn two squares forward
because i'm thinking that makes things
slightly easier for black to start
advancing
this his pawns on the left-hand side of
the board because you of course you've
got these past pawns
try and push them and we now see
anapognachi leaving the computer
yesterday we got completely crazy when
we saw that because we thought that was
cheating they are not allowed to leave
the room but
yana pognachi he when he does that he
has been allowed by the arbiter the
the chess referee to leave so so
no drama here uh but perhaps drama with
the move that magnus made
that's right so actually psychology as
well magnus immediately replied there he
had three or four good moves
he had lots of options but maybe he saw
her on the webcam magnus says he likes
to have his wet players his opponent's
webcam open
maybe he saw an apocalypse he's leaving
the ball so he replied immediately
and the pogba is going to lose an extra
30 seconds an extra minute on his clock
we see magnus advancing a pawn there on
the left side of the board
magnus just pushing pawns slightly
further towards the goal
um yeah if it becomes a pawn race later
black will win those black pawns look
menacing
on that left side and white's bishop
we've talked about it so much white's
bishop's still trapped by its own pawn
yeah that bishop needs to escape somehow
yes it absolutely does need to escape
and the queen has retreated and is now
attacking
the black bishop ooh decisions decisions
how to defend that bishop
that's right chess is all about
undefended unprotected pieces that
bishop is not defended black's knight on
the edge of the board is not defended
so probably actually he's just trying to
gain time he's going to try and improve
his pieces
while attacking the opponent's
undefended pieces magnus carson i expect
him to either move that bishop or just
drop his king forward one square to
protect it
um and then napoli actually will be
forced to decide how to get white's
bishop into the game
it's not going to be easy maybe white's
best goal is to try and trade a pair of
rooks to try and trade the queens
um okay magnus carlson offers to trade
the queens
oh and the bar uh shifts to
yanupornyochi's side this game is just
all over the place maybe he was fed up
with having that night on the edge
or as uh or as our friends on twitter
have
said they've come up with some new
expressions knights on the ropes is
bereft of hopes that's from carl portman
and we have
robert says the night on the frame is
lame
i like these how did we not think of
these before
they're all going into david and your
book of
chess rhymes that's right coming out
sometime
2021 yeah so black has offered a trade
of queens i think magnus carlsen
possibly is relying he's banking on the
fact that white's bishop will never get
back in the game
but personally i would have kept that
decision for later i would have just
improved my pieces
so committal offering to trade queens
magnus we've seen it before he's an end
game expert
i mean if anyone can handle a queenless
position it's him
but white white does have a small
material advantage right now white has
an extra rook
and black has a knight important return
and knight and pawn in total are worth
four
whites rook is worth five we see whites
rook up on the board there attacking an
undefended pawn
white is slightly ahead in terms of
points in terms of material
so trading queens is very risky it's a
dangerous strategy
it is a dangerous strategy but then
again this
bishop we've gone on and on and on about
it this white bishop on the left-hand
side of the board it is such
a bad piece and if magnus can keep it
trapped
then he's going to be well and his
knight has now
jumped in to the center and i think
we've actually captured the imagination
of twitter as well with our octo knights
everyone is calling it and
it was a beautiful night though eight
squares super powerful
oh and magnus shaking his head yeah both
sides not entirely comfortable napoli
actually as well frowning a bit
nepali actually his next goal must be to
trade a set of rooks if he can get
black's rook off the board
he will gain so much more control um
black's rook at the moment doing a great
job of protecting that knight
also i was once told um by an american
gm
that you want it's a bit like all of
your pieces they're like ice cream
flavors you want one of everything so if
black can uh well if white can exchange
off black's rook
then white's winning chances go through
the roof yeah
yeah it's difficult right now i think
bishop is so bad i agree with you there
that because one
black's most dangerous piece is that
rook because you can imagine that that
rook starts to mobilize
it could easily vacuum up some of
white's pawns
on the left-hand side of the board as
well as cause a lot of problems for the
white king
so it's the most dangerous piece so i
really do want napomniachi just to swap
it off
they look like twins now they do they've
got the same posture
and they actually look a little bit like
each other with a beard and
they seem to be moving in sync yeah it's
the rule of attraction right you start
to copy
copy the other person yeah body language
because we do know magnus crossing does
like to have the web camera of his
opponent
up on the screen that's right and we see
white
has taken of our advice there napoli
actually he's just moved his rook across
his root was doing nothing
um if we bring up the board white has
big i mean it's not a huge it's not a
winning threat but it's a big strategic
threat it's a long-term threat if white
can
zoom his rook up to the top of the board
trade off this rook he would give a
check
black would be forced to trade rooks
therefore black stops that he covers
this square
now black is protecting that square
twice white also brings his king towards
the center
black's rook later is going to try and
lift and try and capture some pawns i
think that's what your banker was
worried about
that's why we need to get blacks gone as
soon as possible
uh magnus will be now thinking about how
to do that oh but he's going for glory
immediately he has
pushed his pawn wow that is a that is a
turn up for the books
i'm shocked and napoli actually is
shocked as well um
that is allowing white's bishop to
potentially escape why bishop was
blocked in by his own pawn
if we see a trade of those pawns now
maybe white's bishop has more life
he can finally breathe that being said
black's pawn is edging towards the end
of the board
wants to become a queen i'm wondering
whether he actually wants to be brave
and actually this is a porn sacrifice
wondering whether he is going to try to
maybe not okay so you mean if white
captures that pawn black's pawn will not
capture back in advance
yeah maybe it would just push get a
get another poor passporn because but
anyway we'll see what happens
he is under four minutes on the clock
right now
um i mean i think it's just that one
decision earlier
the trade of queens he spent what five
minutes deciding whether to keep the
queens on the board or not
um i mean imagine if he had five extra
minutes here
he's got decent winning chances if he
can trade off a set of rooks
if he can uh keep as much tension on the
position as possible he can't allow
magnus to get a pawn to the end
or keep those rooks on the board um i
still think i would take white here
personally i think there's more
margin for error with white if it goes
really well wrong
for white maybe he can still make a draw
if it goes really wrong for black
it will be game over so napoleon
actually just needs to speed up
and i mean it starts with the decision
do you trade off that pawn i would take
it immediately
i would take that one off as well
immediately and uh he's
under three minutes on the clock and he
has to make decisions soon
what is he thinking about if perhaps
he's considering
pushing the pawn up and attacking the
knight
yeah so a bit of a decision here i think
you're right you've anchored you need to
move that pawn
or you need to capture your opponent's
pawn with that pawn um
it's a big decision but under two
minutes soon
it's not it's not going to help his
chances if he does fall underneath
we've seen him being outmaneuvered
exactly so he has to be practical
and please he's just mentally willing
him to go take the pawn
play that position it should be level oh
he and he
has pushed the pawn to attack the knight
magnus has jumped in to the position and
is now attacking the knight but just
look at that bishop
oh okay porn takes poor bishop and then
we're going to have a very complicated
position because
well everything to play for that's right
napoli actually shaking his head quite
uh quite vigorously there um white has
been forced to retreat all of his rooks
and i've had this exact
pattern happen in many of my games
before there's no way for white to win
um if we bring the board up maybe we can
keep the players on as well just in case
any action happens just in case any
result happens
we see that black's pawn is so strong
and they will repeat moves
black's pawn in the enemy camp is just
so strong i think the players are
about to repeat um there's just no way
for
white to ever get rid of this pawn uh
black as well is trying to zoom in with
his bishop so therefore the players
repeat moves white black gives a check
white blocks what black returns white
blocks and so on the players are
repeating the position this will be a
draw um the players have actually agreed
to a draw
um just no way for white to make
progress napolitani
missed opportunity again yes he does not
look happy and we know what this
means with the draw in this game we will
have that fourth game
and uh he has to win it
he has to win with the black pieces it
can be done difficult task
difficult task what do you think
napoleon i will do he has 15 minutes
before a game with black pieces against
the
champion and it's win or nothing i would
get some fresh air i would just splash
it's all about one game now just to get
the rest it's just a one game shootout
and and for magnus carlsen going into
that game with
white pieces all he need is the draws
what do we expect from the world
champion pure enjoyment
do you think he actually because he's
been looking you know a little bit tired
all day do you think he will actually
enjoy that game yeah i think he will go
out there smiling
you know because whatever happens it's
okay you know if he loses he still gets
another shot he has to play the blitz
whatever that's
nuisance but okay but uh if he draws or
wins then that's it
he's into the final all right well we
are
in for some very exciting chance for the
rest of the day david
um we are waiting now to be joined by or
our good friend uh grandmaster simon
williams and well he's not quite ready
so
as we wait for him david um do you think
jana pognaty is able to just
forget another lost opportunity here and
and
really get back ready for a big fight
he needs to completely forget he also
needs to be optimistic and forget that
he's playing magnus carson
yesterday we saw in the last game of the
day he was a point down but he was happy
to take a draw because he thought he had
no chance of winning he needs to be
optimistic
he needs to just gamble now it's i mean
he'll go home a draw or loss it's the
same thing he might as well gamble and
throw everything at magnus all right
well simon williams is ready uh ginger
gm grandmaster simon williams hi simon
how are you
i'm very good thanks you're all good we
are all good and we're so happy for all
the excitement that we have uh
in the end of this this day what's your
take on everything that is happening
i mean again the days just get better
and better with the excitement and uh
we've seen i think the right approach
from yan against magnus
you can't get into an ending against
magnus you have to go for his
king i mean at the end of the day chess
is decided by checkmate
there's no point messing about just get
your pieces in and attack magnus
and i think when yan's been doing that
he's been getting some very good
positions
as we saw in the first round so it's
been very exciting the other match
also of interest with hikaru and wesley
so
fighting it out and with one more game
to go it's clear what they need to do
they need to
put that kitchen sink into the position
and both
try to win that's hikaru and yan
in the last game so yeah very exciting
and we have actually now
gone into the last game between hikar
nakamura and wesley
so they have played all draws today
wesley so won the first day
that means hikaru nakamura is win or
nothing for him in this game and my
three favorite
favorite british chess players can you
please
explain what has happened in the
beginning of this game
um well to me to my eyes it looks like
okay i mean wesley is so strong
and uh wesley's just trying to play it
quite safe
he doesn't want to risk anything he
looks quite calm there can we tell
anything from his face you know maybe
he's a little bit of poke tell
i think he's very relaxed and at the
moment
things are okay but one good thing in
hikaru's um i say on his side
is that all the pieces are on the board
and in order to win the game you want
complications you want to keep pieces on
the board
which gives you more tactical
opportunities later on
so simon i have a question um did you
see the last game between wesley so
nakamura
i mean such a quick draw would you yeah
would you have gone for that in
either player's shoes would you have
ended that game and just
left it down to this one big decider or
would you have tried to fight especially
from nakamura's side
i'm i think it's very tough when you've
got the black pieces and you're playing
someone
as well prepared as wesley so wesley so
must spend all his time on openings his
openings are so
good and i think you know wesley fought
okay a draw gets me that little bit
nearer to the finishing mark
on the other hand hikaru thinks okay if
i draw this one i've got
white in the last round so i can
understand why they did go for a draw
i probably would have gone a bit crazy
and gone down even in a blaze of glory
or uh you know or sort of uh one in a
blaze of glory
but it's personal style i think
all right um yeah i have one question so
if you were the coach
of both hikaru and uh and the napolita
what music would you play for them
get them inspired oh
i like this question i do too i i
it would have to be a little bit of ac
dc maybe a bit of guns and roses
or a bit of fire starter by the prodigy
i feel like
so yeah what about you guys maybe not
any frank sinatra that's far too calming
i need something a bit of punch i would
like i would like tina turner you're
simply the best we've been talking about
that song
just get the confidence going uh i think
the whole world knows by this point that
um i like a song after mulan i'll make a
man out of you the lyrics just resound
with chess
it's very inspirational what were you
ivanka eminem
oh yes okay which which eminem song till
i collapse
that's my morning yoga song wow
all right well i can kind of see it till
i collapse just fight till the beginning
exactly yeah all right well actually
inside we've been also talking about
chess books today
a lot of the viewers are interested in
getting in into some chess reading
what's your favorite chess book
there's two chess books that come to
mind one is called chess for tigers
which is like a really good beginner's
book it's very amusing
and it's got like lots of nice pictures
of tigers in it
but it's a really good book for the
psychological side of chess
and it's great for beginners so yeah
let's just stick with chess for tigers
that's that has to be brought well if
you want to impress well i can say to
that
simon is snap she already said it
you have good safety ivanka so yeah
just for targets that that's going to be
on my wishlist for for christmas
definitely
um and we do hear some moves uh david uh
what's
happening that's right so just on the
last time wesley so he dropped his rook
on an open line attacking the white
queen
nakamura he has brought his queen to
safety we've seen a trade of pawns as
well
as simon mentioned okay a couple of
pawns have left the board but all of the
pieces are there
more importantly and that does mean more
opportunity later means more tension
right now
um wesley so maybe he'll get nervous at
some point and allow a trick with some
of those pieces
i like white's position he controls the
left side of the board
um who would you take here simon
um what i think this you know hikaru has
done exactly
the thing he should be doing he's he's
not gone too crazy actually i mean i
i would probably just freak out and just
do something completely ridiculous he's
playing
it quite patiently but he's keeping the
queens on the board
as you mentioned david he's got that
little bit more space
on the queen side and when you control
space it's like controlling space on a
football pitch
you've got many more options to do
things with so
i have to say at the moment yeah i mean
it's fairly even
but hikaru is keeping the chances alive
which is what we want
and wesley so is looking very
into the game hikaru nakamura is uh
thinking
and we have this all american battle
here and obviously we're missing fabiano
caruana in this tournament hopefully
he'll
he will um at some point join us in the
champions chess tour but uh
and we have a move what's happening
that's right so um white has just
recaptured
uh peace in the center of the board with
his bishop i'm slightly surprised i
would have captured with my knight i
love my knights in the center of the
board
bishops are long-range pieces they do
just as good a job
behind the army as they do in the center
so a bit of a strange one from nakamura
but still early days as simon mentioned
well i did mention all these three very
good americans
with three brits in in the studio and
also
uh you simon um who is the best american
chess player
i am the best american chess player well
i think it would have to be fabian
fabiano carowanna because he's been in
the world championship match he's
challenged
for the highest title in chess um
on top of that you mean these two
players playing they they are just
biting at his heels hikari's got a
massive following
online and wesley so well he's he's
pretty good i mean it's very close at
the top there
all right well simon i know you have to
get back to your ginger gm stream
on twitch and we thank you so much for
joining us again
and we look so much forward to seeing
you tomorrow in the finals
it's gonna be great yeah i'm looking
forward to it have a great stream put
some eminem on
and enjoy yourselves yeah so thank you
simon yes eminem your favorite artist
jovanka yes it is fantastic all right
well
uh does it look like these players have
been listening to some inspirational
music before the start of this game
i think so i mean i really did like what
hikaru did i think he provoked
wesley so to make some advances and
look at black's position you know the
black queen
had to make a retreat to defend the
night and what and hikaru
has taken the space in the queen and
he's just look at him
he looks like he can't believe the the
quick turn of events because now he
is fighting for equality that's right i
really i mean if we can bring the board
up i just love what
hikaru nakamura has done on the last
couple of turns um in this position
we've just seen the move uh pawn push
from wesley so
attacking this bishop in the center of
the world we mention this bishop maybe
he doesn't want to be in the center
it would be very natural to retreat here
but hikaru nakamura says no
you're going to attack me but i'm going
to counter-attack you i'm not going to
go back
he just drops the pawn forward opening
up a line against the black king
more importantly attacking this knight
with his queen this undefended knight
um wesley so just dropped this queen
back to defend it as ivanka mentioned
this queen is very bad now
and again white bishop is attacked but
hikaru nakamura said no i'm not scared
of you i'm not going to retreat
i'm going to drop my knight forward now
if this bishop is captured why it's nice
it's going to attack the black queen
the queen will have to move and white's
going to capture an undefended piece in
the center of the board this would be
a winning position for white instead we
have seen a couple of developments
we saw that black just dropped his
knight in the middle here we have seen a
couple of trades
but hikaru nakamura he has to be happy
this pawn is extremely far advanced it
will be joined by its buddy here
these two pawns against what one pawn
here um
hikara nakamura he's banking everything
on this left-hand side of the board
but he's got what he wants a really
imbalanced position with lots of life
left in it
yeah once again this is those pawns
versus those pieces
and uh this time i'm not going to take
the side of the pawns
i'm slightly concerned actually you
prefer black white pawns to blacks this
time
yes i i prefer the the dynamism of
white's pieces because i just love that
that night on the frame is lame but this
one isn't
isn't lame because it has a lovely
square to jump into
white's bishop can counter black's
bishop and just put
lovely kind of pressure the only danger
that i'm slightly concerned about
is that the white king because you
always have to remember about the king
is unprotected it doesn't have any
pieces to surround it
so therefore i would be slightly
concerned with that but if i keep that
in mind every single move then i should
be go
and what should be good that's right and
we just see a quick flurry of moves
white is attacking the center
this is the chest is all about the
center of the board especially when lots
of pieces remain
white is attacking this pawn three times
now and that pawn is only defended twice
so great stuff from nakamura he's very
much trying to put pressure on wesley so
hoping that he'll crack
the game is still roughly balanced but
white is the one
forcing black to defend right now and
once again we see
we're back to high school three very
strong uh the popular girls
three strong black pawns and then this
time they're really in the center here
they're just the center of everyone's
attention they are in the center they
are quite menacing
so it will be hikira's job to put
pressure on them
to make it very unpleasant for wesley
and
of course wesley has the momentum on his
side so he really does need to act
very dynamically yeah the fight will
revolve around whether that gang can
stay together
or whether one of them will be captured
one of them will be split up from the
others
it's very much a fight about that i'm
getting all these uh high school
hollywood movies in my head
hikaru nakamura split up the mean girls
he's trying his best yeah he's trying
his best and wesley so
um he doesn't want to be in this
situation he remember he forced to draw
in his last game maybe because he's
feeling a bit tense a bit nervous so
the longer this one is tense the longer
the game goes on
the more nervous he will become nakamura
looks focused leaning forward
i'm liking what he's done he's been in
this situation so many times before
and we have to remind everyone it is all
or nothing for hikaru nakamura he needs
a win in this game if he wants to go to
the final and
if he does we will have tie breaks so
i mean i'm rooting for all players but
obviously i'm hoping for tie breaks
because those are so much fun yeah we
just love to see more chess exactly
and blitz games five minutes each side i
mean that's the
kind of the peak of excitement that's
the most exciting thing that i know that
i just love watching myself yeah and the
the chess equivalent to the white
knuckle ride has to be the armageddon
where it's
no time added five minutes against four
or four minutes
black will if they if black draws it
will be
victory for black oh my god it gets to
0.008 your second oh and in this very
second also magnus carl's nina pogba
actually started their
fourth and final game jana pogniacci
needs to win that game if he wants to
take it to tie breaks
so drama going on all over the place
here
yeah that's right in that game um
they've only just started two or three
moves being played but
imagine napoli actually yeah he's going
to throw everything at carson
just like nakamura is doing here against
wesley so
it is slightly more difficult for napoli
actually though with black carlson
rarely loses with white the only times
he ever loses with white is when
he's going for the win when he maybe
when he over
stretches and overpresses napoli
actually i think
it's gonna be a struggle it will be a
struggle i agree with you oh look at the
bar
after that move and yeah look at
nakamura's face after that move he just
leaned back and frowned um we do see um
wesley so going for the white king
ivanka mentioned it white's king has no
pieces around it no protection but maybe
this was the wrong moment maybe wesley
so
just prematurely went for that attack
he's looking up and
looking up at the ceiling there maybe
just trying to work out whether he was
correct and going for it if we bring the
board up
we can see that um wesley so with his
last move jumping in with the knight
he's trying to get to
either this pawn to give a check or he's
going to jump into this unprotected
square to give a check
also maybe he wants to line up his queen
against the white king
but maybe this pawn now is
the big weakness maybe white has time to
just capture this pawn
maybe he will throw up a pawn to attack
the black queen instead
he plays his pawn up to attack the black
knight very calm by nakamura he
doesn't care about the fact his king is
a bit naked it doesn't have any
protection around it he's just attacking
the black knight
forcing that knight to decide do you
jump forward do you jump forward or do
you go back
huge decisions for wesley so um either
way
nakamura is going to win one of those
mean girls win one of those pawns in the
sense of the board nakamura doing well i
think
yeah i agree with you nakamura
definitely doing well but wesley
with it has the ability to mix things up
because we've seen it is not two
computers playing chess
but two humans and they're vulnerable to
all sorts of
fails for failings that's right and
wesley just puts his knight in the
center of the board there
a very human move but again maybe not
the most accurate move
nakamura he has a choice now do you
capture that pawn in the middle of the
board
do you use your rook in the middle there
zoom up and take that pawn do you take
that same pawn with the knight
lots of options i'm surprised wesley so
looks so relaxed personally as black i
would be thinking i'm about to lose a
pawn oh wait
and now he started thinking that's right
i mean he's acting confident maybe maybe
it's because he knows hikaru can see him
that being said i think wesley he would
have wanted a more controlled game this
one
anything can happen he's down right now
he's about to lose a pawn
he could still go to that white king but
either way it's going to be chaotic
he very much wanted a bit more of a
relaxing game maybe the queen's off the
board
and he is talking to himself here um
maybe realizing he's again not playing
very accurately and
i mean imagine if he actually loses this
game he's been
set so many chances today and then
ending up in thai breaks i guess that
would
make hikaru nakamura a big favorite yes
it would make
hikaru the absolute big favorite you
know especially because he's been riding
his luck
every time i think okay he's down and
out but no
he comes back up and finds a resource so
absolutely
some great stuff i'm thinking really
hard here yeah i think maybe he's
feeling the
uh i mean it's just a momentous occasion
this one game it's
do or die time and i think he's feeling
the pressure hikaru
when he's feeling super confident he'll
just play a move and he'll worry about
the consequences later
but it's a big decision to take the pawn
because you know we
did mention it before the white king is
vulnerable it has no protection
and black will basically start playing
like a mad man
to open up the right hand side of the
board
so that would be like pushing those
pawns forward anything
to hunt down that king so it's a okay
so he has well he's played a little move
that i didn't
wasn't surprised wasn't expecting rather
and he has attacked
the queen by pushing the pawn so
yeah yeah interesting for a strange move
i think white had two great options
white could have captured that pawn in
the middle of the board why could also
just maybe develop his bishop as well if
he was feeling a bit more modest
if we bring the analysis board up we see
that hikaru nakamura maybe he's setting
a trap for wesley so
wesley so now his queen is attacked he
shuffles it across to safety
if he had captured this pawn this would
have been a huge mistake white would
take this pawn with his knight lining up
something against the black king the
black king would move and white would
have another
we call this a skewer the queen would be
attacked the rook would be attacked
behind it
instead we see a flurry of moves maybe
we catch up with the game
and we see wesley so avoided that trick
and we see lots and lots of trades the
queens are about to leave the board now
but i'm not sure maybe nakamura he's
playing safety first chess when he
doesn't he shouldn't be doing this
i don't understand why wesley so can't
just trade off the queens now
in the middle of the board the queens
will leave the board sooner or later
black's going to win the pawn back and
it's happening and it's happening the
queens are off and i
fully expect that uh that uh black
will start to munch on some points oh
we're seeing he's sacrificed his knight
in the middle of the board black's rook
is attacking that knight in the middle
but nakamura he's gambling it's all
about that pawn now that pawn that's
just advanced on the
top of the board um that white the most
furthest advanced pawn
um nakamura he's gambling everything on
that pawn
if wesley can stop it then the game will
be a draw at the very least for black
oh this one's attached this is tense you
know because uh my instinct reacted
there is
a knight that can be taken let me take
it
that's right and um if we jump into the
position wesley so he's going to have a
think here because this is so
complicated
um that wasn't meant to be a pun it is
so complicated
maybe if we bring up the board black and
capture a free knight here in the middle
it looks like black's just winning a
night but white is going to maybe either
advance this pawn either capture this
pawn
or a very cool move and he's done it oh
we're going to see it happen are we
going to see it
on the board i think that was the only
move i think he had to take that knight
otherwise white was just going to be
winning with those
far advanced pawns on the left-hand side
yeah can white force upon home now
um we see that actually the computer
stockfish says there's only one move for
white to keep the balance every other
move is losing now for white
maybe this bishop move is so hard for a
human to find this to cover this square
meaning that the black rook cannot drop
behind the pawns white is still going to
try and promote
still not trying to make this pawn a
queen but this is so hard for nakamura
to find will he find this bishop move
okay so that's the one we are looking
for now
yes and every other move loses we see
the evaluation that bishop the bishop
forward
and look at hikaru he car looks stressed
he
thinks oh my god i've made a mistake
that's right
wow we are looking for the bishop to the
to the rink of the board here yes to
right to the edge of the board the
bishop needs to develop
and it needs to get going
and hikari thinking for one minute now
can he find this bishop move that's all
we're wondering about right now
the problem is this bishop move even if
he finds it the position is still
equal the position is still level wesley
so if he's accurate should be able to
guide the game towards a draw
which is enough for him to qualify for
the final nakamura he had
so many opportunities he just rushed it
he had three or four good moves
he sped down this line um he played his
last five six moves very quickly
now wesley is winning and the rosley
retreats but now the night can come
now the knight can come and attack the
pawn this is the point
that's right um nakamura he's trying to
use his rook to zoom
up to the end of the board to help his
pawn that white pawn at the top he's
going to try and get it to the end
but black's knight can just drop back
and take that pawn off the board
black is winning now if he retreats his
knight we see the stockfish the computer
evaluation black has two winning moves
everything else
loses he has to retreat his knight right
he's done it and he's done it and he's
yeah and he has retreated the night he's
to attack the pawn
and uh hikaru is shaking his head oops
and yeah he i think he probably saw that
position
seven or eight moves ago it's just he
didn't see that the knight could retreat
backwards night moves they're the
hardest moves to see wesley so
showing off now sacrificing his knight
he's about to win
yeah you're going to see black's rook
capture that white bishop
black gave a double attack it's all over
for hikaru
hikaru is knocked out actually wesley so
is completely winning here but he knows
a draw is enough
wesley so takes the draw and moves on to
the final
wow wow all right well
first of all we have the first finalist
ready it is
wesley so the american he has beaten his
american rival hikaru nakamura in the
semi-final
and he is now ready for the final
and what a way to do it ivanka yeah what
a way to do it you know it looked like
he was on the edge hikaru was gonna
pull it back but wow you know with some
accurate calculation
he saw everything and yeah wow he was
deserved victor
desert victor and are you a little
surprised
uh david that wesley so won this
semi-final match
i'm maybe not surprised by the result
because i think it was 50 50 nakamura so
they're both so strong i'm just
i'm surprised in the style he did it so
convincingly never really in trouble
and today he could have won by a huge
margin he was winning the first two
games
he was winning the last game in the
final position wesley so i mean
he cruised to the final there uh
impressive impressive performance
so wesley's so ready for the skilling
open final do you think he will
come in there tomorrow ivanka just full
of self-confidence after beating
such a great player that hikar nakamura
is yes he has
every reason to be happy because he's
there playing for the final
you know and he'll be facing who knows
actually
yeah who knows it will be magnus girls
who knows
exactly so he'll be absolutely
absolutely ecstatic because that is what
every player dreams about going to the
final
all right uh we actually have wesley so
now joining us wesley so congratulations
so much
on going to the skilling open final
yeah thank you very much thank you to
all of you i'm still very bewildered
with what happened in the last game
because i was
fighting for my life and i was
trying to generate some counter play but
then he just planted his night in the
end
but i'm still not sure what happened
there what has this day been like for
you wesley because you've been in
winning positions
as far as we can see um in many games
here um and then it has ended in draws
all the all the way here
yeah yeah that's very very very
confusing day i think higher and i
weren't playing well
uh well i obviously have to try to win
in all the games
while i just have to play it safe so in
that case uh
i have nothing to lose because it
doesn't really matter whether i lose by
two and a half
or whether i lose by four by three three
zero
so i just wanted to to play my game and
uh yeah well not winning the first game
was very disheartening
of course so wesley can you talk us
through that emotional journey you
mentioned nearly winning the first game
you nearly won the second one as well
how are you feeling especially as the
last game approached
yeah that's true today has been a very
confusing day
honestly i have no idea what's happening
in the end
uh yeah i think taking the breather on
game through was a big a big help for me
but uh yeah in general this event if you
want to try to
to forget the last game right away
whatever happens and move on try to take
each game
as if it's the very first round but it's
not always uh
not always easy and i think here and i
are very confused already what's
happening in the end
um but uh but yeah i just write i just
try to move on and play better but
it's always very tricky because uh
hickory is a very
uh tactical and very slippery and he's
he
makes use of all his chances and he
never gives up he has this tremendous
fighting spirit
so he'll just keep fighting on until
he's doesn't have any chances left
so when we get down to a minute or or
or two minutes on the clock he plays
just much better while
simply panic with with very little time
but uh yeah i don't i don't know it's
been very confusing
so wesley what has kept you motivated
during this tournament
uh during this tournament well first of
all i have nothing to lose right
because uh after my first game with uh
taymor i realized i probably should be
able to determine already so i i have
nothing to lose i'll just i just
give my best and play hard every game
try to
get comfortable positions uh
motivation release just to just to play
well
uh yeah play some good chess
and uh wesley we still don't know who
you will face in the final do you sort
of have
someone you hope that will win this uh
seven final match between yonder
pogniacc and magnus carlsen
let's see ian has to draw yeah and he
has to win
the last game with black yeah it doesn't
seem very likely looking at the
position uh oh they hope yeah i guess
you'll always face magnus every single
time in the finals
doesn't matter what tournament and you
did actually beat him we know that
very well in the world championship in
fischer random chess
so you do you feel confidence if it is
magnus cross and you will face
yeah if we if we play chess 960 i feel
very confident
all right wesley oh yeah you were saying
yeah but i mean chess and chess 960 are
just two completely different games
because magnus knows already the typical
plans and typical setups and the
typical maneuvers in basically every
single opening
all right well are you feeling fired up
and looking forward to the finals in the
skilling open
yeah i'm just very happy to be here i'm
still very happy to be here totally
didn't expect it uh it's always a great
honor to
face magnus in the match especially in
the finals
i think the last time i played in the
magnus chester was back in
july and i faced
magnus right away in the quarter finals
so it was a very unlucky pairing and i
didn't
move on but it's again it's a great
honor and a great pleasure to
uh face uh powerful opponents like
magnus carlsen and hikaru nakamura
so i hope to be able to put up a put up
a good pipe
put up a worthy fight with uh
interesting games and hopefully i can uh
i can trade blows with magnus all right
one more question um so have your cats
been watching the game
[Laughter]
yeah yeah fancy bar yeah definitely i
think he's gotten used to it i
i uh i'm gonna leave the door open for
him so he can come in and out
but he doesn't like it when when the
doors are closed but i think
right now i've i've been playing for a
week i think he's
uh he's gotten used to it uh i
so but but he enjoys playing chess he
likes playing jeff and then the the very
minute i open the door he comes right in
and checks everything that's happening
yeah
fantastic well uh wesley say hi to
sansibar from us and
good luck in the finals tomorrow yeah
thank you so much
be exciting thank you wesley all right
wesley so is ready for the finals he was
very much talking about uh facing magnus
crossing he might face yana pognachi
this game is not orianna pogniacci has
to win this fourth game
to take it to tie breaks and just
judging by the bar david
it looks like he's uh quite good in this
position that's right i really like
black's position to be honest um
we have just seen the queen queens leave
the board just on that last turn
and actually it's magnus carlsen this
time who's maybe um
allowing just the momentum to turn
against him
in this position just a very normal
position wesley so he said himself
he thinks black probably doesn't have
too many winning chances if magnus
carson just sits still
just maybe moves his rook moves his
bishop doesn't do anything it's very
hard for black to break out black hasn't
got much space his pawns are very
well they're not far advanced at all
he's very cramped instead magnus allowed
a trade
and allowed this pawn to capture doubled
pawns
normally quite controversial but black
controls all of the central squares now
more importantly his bishop is unleashed
and
we saw a queen trade normally this
favors magnus the end game expert
but in this position suddenly black
jumps out with his bishop black's bishop
is a great piece this other bishop is
also a great piece
two fantastic bishops there i love
black's position
i like these doubled pawns actually
controlling the center
lots of tension magnus is an endgame
expert but napoli actually doing well
yeah i agree with you there david magnus
um nepomniacci is
doing very well and i really do love
those
action happening on the left hand side
of the board where that rook
is bearing down it's basically every
sicilian player's dream
that's right and white just advancing
his pawn there slightly this is a pawn
sacrifice by white
by magnus carson black can now capture
that knight on the left side of the wood
with his bishop
that being said black's bishop is so
strong in the middle it's probably best
to leave it there for now
personally i think maybe napoli actually
he didn't need to rush into the center
with his bishop
he had plenty of options maybe now
magnus carson
oh he's done it he's taken it he has
gone for material perhaps it's just too
tempting
because why not be a pawn up against
magnus carlsen and make him suffer and
the bar shifts over to magnus's side
with this uh these moves yeah i think
that was maybe just a bit of a greedy
decision by napoleon he's won a pawn
temporarily
but more importantly he's just wasted
three moves with his bishop to take that
pawn
now we see magnus bring his rook across
the left side he's targeting a black
pawn
um along that line um great play by
magnus carson he
it shows sometimes being materialistic
it's not the best thing
especially if it's just a pawn white
pieces have suddenly improved a lot
white's bishops are soon going to join
the action white's rooks are great
yeah we're not butts
you have to also remember that the pawn
that is the extra pawn
is actually one of the double pawns as
well and the double bonds
can in certain situations count as just
basically one
big porn that's right so blackies are
pulling up but doubled pawns so
not a huge advantage meanwhile i like
bishops especially the positions
starting to open up
black's bishop retreating there to its
start square
it's always depressing if you have to
retreat your pieces and we see the bar
as it does swing slightly towards magnus
carlsen's side
i think the last we joined it and we
maybe we cursed him
yeah the commentator's curse oh and we
want
tie breaks we do want high breaks
and what more spectacular tie break than
having magnus carlsen
fight for his life against ian and palm
naturally that would be just awesome
that would be
fantastic magnus is sharing why he's
well championed just uh
look at how he's commanding the position
his rooks are on open lines
this bishop that is on the right hand
side dark square bishop is getting
ready to mobilize and uh yeah absolutely
everything working together
well the only thing i know about magnus
perhaps maybe his only
weakness is that he he just loves
winning
so much and it almost seems especially
in situations where
like this where every other chess player
would just go for the draw just
get that draw just get to the final it
seems he loves in this situation to just
tell everyone no i'm gonna go for the
win and i'm gonna be risky
yeah it's occasionally weakness mostly
it's the strength yeah
um it allows him to kind of assert his
dominance over everyone else that's why
he's the
the top dog the the big boss but um
yeah i think in this position if he has
a chance to just end the match now to
end the game
he'd probably take it but yeah he would
definitely take in this position before
the game because white is the one in
control
actually maybe if we bring up the board
we can see why white is doing well
this bishop now doing nothing at the
edge of the board personally i would
maybe just bring it back attack this
pawn this pawn is only defended by
black's knight
um okay instead he improves his rooks
these rooks are going to
team up double up against this weakness
then the bishop is going to come back
and take this pawn
all of white's pieces are very nicely
placed black's king in the middle
not so great black's rook doing nothing
out here black's bishop
very badly placed yeah i mean this is
dream time for magnus
this is definitely dream time i really
like the way he's moved
this rook rather than rushing with the
bishop because
just moving the rook forward there's
sudden traps in the air like if the
knight tries to jump forward then the
rook could be in danger of
getting trapped this is the black rook
yeah that's right so um black um
yeah black has to decide what to do how
to get his rook into the game
um maybe he could try and jump forward
with that knight
maybe for sure if we get the board to
show you what ivanka means there with a
couple of traps
um black could try and bring his knight
forward but white's bishop would
uh bring itself back to the
start line to attack that black rook
yeah okay moving the night forward isn't
the best move right now but it's
definitely in the air
and uh i just love this whole idea that
this rook
is potentially vulnerable on that dark
square
that's right so we see the stockfish
evaluation the computer evaluation the
moves
just above the board there on the top
right hand side of the screen
black does have a few moves all of them
though even the best moves
do give a small advantage for white
remember though that magnus carson does
only need a draw so any advantage
is enough for him um any advantage it
just means that he'll be able to
kind of bully nepomniacci into more
trades into
slowly hoovering everything off the
board we saw it in there last game
yesterday
all the pawns disappeared all the pieces
disappeared magnus carlsen he's going to
be thinking
about how he can um just safely without
any risk at all guide this game towards
a draw yeah
and the pognyacci been thinking for two
minutes now and uh
well magnus carlsen still has less time
on the clock uh but nabomiacci made his
move what happened
oh and the bar shifts moreover to minus
that's right and we see that um in that
position black did
castle his king so we've talked about
that move before castling
bring your king across two squares and
the rook over two squares that's always
allowed as long as your king hasn't
moved and your rook hasn't moved
and as long as you're cut not castling
through an attacked square so
even though this is move 23 it's not too
late to castle black brought his king to
safety
but actually maybe it wasn't good to
bring to the king to safety the king
would never have been attacked there
because white doesn't have a queen so
black did castle
bring his king further away from the
center maybe not a good idea
and as we mentioned white bishop just
drops back eyeing up a pawn along that
diagonal yeah
exactly and we have a tweet from tim
wolf who believes that this pawn
sacrificed by magnus carlsen
against nepo could be a master stroke to
win game four
and the skilling open semi-finals and
yeah if you do want to join in the
conversation and the fun
and perhaps get featured on the show
then please
please do tweet us using the hashtag
chesschamps
i definitely think jannapony actually
needs some social media energy
if he's gonna be able to fight back here
and i i
i can't help but remembering all the
games we have been commentating here for
um seven days now six days seven days
and
so many of them has just been oh and i
think magnus can take this to a draw and
then
sudden changes all the time winning
losing
well the players have been very
unpredictable extremely unpredictable i
have to say and it's probably the
the rapid chess i mean time
obviously um plays a role here yeah
absolutely i mean that's one of the
factors this is why this is not computer
chess this is human chess
people make mistakes people play
brilliant moves
people miss things and you know it's
just a joy to watch
yeah that's why magnus carlsen is the
world champion he sees these mistakes
coming he can predict
what types of mistakes his opponents
will make he knows he doesn't play
perfect chess himself
nobody plays perfect chess but he knows
what his opponents are going to do in
advance
maybe he saw that pawn sacrifice that
the tweet
mentioned that tim wall's tweet
mentioned magnus would have seen that
coming a mile away he would have said
okay napoli actually
he's going to try and grab that pawn but
then the game's going to turn around
and magnus carson we've seen him up
against up against it so many times in
worse positions losing positions
he somehow knows that his opponents
aren't going to finish him off he's just
so tenacious
so hard to beat that's why he's the
world champion you also have to remember
that stockfish really likes this
this position stock fish being the
engine but
magnus is actually a pawn down hmm yeah
so when my when when the computer is
saying that you know that your position
is slightly better and you're pawn down
then you know you have a good position
in terms of human chess
that's right and white's last move with
that bishop dropping it back is
threatening to win the pawn back
if white wins that pawn back he'll never
lose the game and just
completely takes away the risk we
mentioned those double pawns for black
those pawns are still doubled in the
center
and black's last move ambitious this
shows
okay the bar has switched towards the
white side
this shows napoli actually he's gambling
now he knows that last move isn't a good
move
but he can't let the game fizzle out
into a draw he needs to take risk
yeah so he's playing moves that aren't
the best but maybe create the most
tension and create some traps for magnus
carlsen and obviously i mean
okay taking these risky moves it it does
force magnus carlsen to
to think on his time and use that clock
and
perhaps make some mistakes yeah well the
thing is with magnus is that he's so
objective about it because he looked at
the position and said well ultimately
you're not threatening anything
so i'm just gonna grab off that pawn
with a bishop but okay
things are gonna start heating up now
that's right we've seen a couple of
pawns leave the board white's just
retreated with the bishop in the center
there
very calm move by magnus garson actually
it just shows he was thinking in the
pontiac's time
i think he was actually inside the
pontiac's mind because
i would never have predicted those last
three moves by black magnus carlson he
reacted immediately
it means he knew exactly what napolita
is going to do he knows his opponent so
well he knows exactly how they can
imagine facing someone who can read your
thoughts read your mind
it's depressing crash course in
psychology
okay so the pawn is has marched forward
and wow so calmly captured
by magnus carson but now the king
the white king is opposite the black
rook and so if the knight
moves anywhere there will be something
that we call a discovered jack
that's right so if we bring the board up
um we can see napoli actually he's just
discovering
he's just uh kind of having a think
about how to make the most of this
discover check
once the knight moves this will be
checked against the black king he just
has too much choice though
where do you bring the knight do you
move it this way to attack the bishop do
you take this pawn back
um he has captured the pawn magnus
carson he's spent about five seconds in
total in his last
five moves so fast that must be i mean
talking about psychology
again that must be so frustrating
brianna pognetti just
taking these very risky moves trying to
push for that wind and then minus
crossing the bus
oh okay i see what you do i have a plan
that's right and the more pieces to
leave the board the more pawns leave the
board the closer magnus carson is
yeah three-minute time advantage now as
well yeah and i i
and also napoleon is worse on the board
because suddenly those two bishops
have come alive and uh
napoli actually desperately trying to
create threats by
retreating the knights to attack the
white bishop
and you see it on his face he's almost
about to give up
do you have some more fighting spirit in
you yanupomnyachi
then this is the time he did win against
magnus carson with a mouse slip in the
first game of the whole skilling open
right maybe that's his best chance now
i imagine if that actually decided this
wow this semi-final
another mouse slip well actually the bar
shifts back to center now
yeah so the position becomes a little
bit more level with
more pieces that have been traded off in
light of the
match situation you saw magnus trade one
of his advantages which was the bishop
pair
for simplicity so he's gotten rid of
some pieces
and now he you can see that his rook and
the bishop
they have got their eye on the pawn on
the left-hand side of the board
and uh still more trades are probably
going to happen that's right so magnus
again
knowing that there were better moves in
the position but in this situation it's
better to play fast moves that guide the
game towards a draw he doesn't need to
try to win
um ivanka mentioned his last move
attacking this pawn bishop lining up on
this pawn
look at lying up in this pawn and
probably actually defending across the
line here
defending laterally indirectly defending
this pawn
but magnus has the chance he can trade
rooks now
if he wants to he can just keep the
tension he can just also bring his rook
to attack the black king
indirectly lots of choice napoli
actually very much
reacting to what magnus does i think he
can guide this game towards a draw
if that's what he wants two minute time
advantage as well
yeah absolutely and uh we have a tweet
from jesse rankins who basically sums up
the situation the most important
reminder from magnus is
magnus and ian's last game don't get
greedy carefully improve your pieces and
play
positional chess so yeah it just sums it
up there beautifully
magnus likes to play with all his pieces
and he yeah he just did it beautifully
doesn't matter about material
just get every piece of the uh if
every army i'll get there
every piece working
well we see magnus thinking do you think
this is so comfortable for him now that
his mind maybe is shifting
towards that final that will be played
tomorrow no i i
i don't think magnus is the type of guy
who loses
focus and loses concentration just have
a look at him in the webcam he looks
absolutely present in the game i don't
think he's even
dawned on him about the final he just
wants to play the best chess
yeah that's right i think the only thing
making him pause right now
is that he has a lot of options and he's
just trying to figure out the quickest
way to force the draw
there we see again the bar zooms
slightly back towards the middle but
that just means that
magnus carson he's one step away now
well he's one step closer
to trading off all those pieces he's
offering another trade with his rook
both of white's rooks now are looking at
the same black rook but either way
black's gonna have to make a decision
about what to do there and
black will not be able to keep that rook
on the board um
we're just inching closer to safety for
magnus carson yeah
he will have to he has to try to
maintain itself on that line
so we know janna pognashi needs to keep
pieces on the board if
he wants to somehow find a win in this
position but
do you think he is there any way he can
avoid
trading those rooks now i can't see one
for you
no actually no i can't see any and is
that what he is
thinking about now what he is looking at
is there any way i can keep my rooks
on the board here yeah um it must be
he's got two options or maybe three
options he can
if we bring the board up he'll be
deciding upon whether to just defend
this rook
allow this rook to be captured on this
square or maybe he can capture
this one or this guy all of them i think
should lead towards a draw the problem
is none of those options
leave enough tension they don't set any
tricks for magnus carlsen the position
is so simple
uh magnus carson is just going to start
hoovering pawns off the board this pawn
will soon disappear
off the board these two might get traded
every pawn that leaves the water
is close yeah and one thing that i can
see that could be potentially quite
dangerous is if
black were to remove the rook on the
left hand side and try to grab that pawn
that suddenly became free
then uh the the bishop and the king are
on the same
line so they are very very very
vulnerable to
a kind of a pin something that we call a
pin
so you mean if black captures this pawn
yes ah okay
um and then we would see a trade on this
square and as your vanco mentioned a pin
you pin and you win this bishop cannot
move um the rook can defend it but then
this bishop is doomed exactly so
that's so that this is the big problem
in the position okay so we've had a few
moves if you go back
that's right so we have seen a couple of
moves being played black's just
blockaded a pawn now
with his bishop um yeah i think this one
still much in the realms of a draw but
napoli actually just trying to play
trying to hope that magnus gets nervous
he traded rooks on the square
the bishop just blocks very safe stuff
this pawn
is a strength right now but maybe it'll
become a weakness on a good day for
napomiacci
um i think magnus here he'll just be
deciding do you push your pawn forward
do you try and trade off more pawns try
and get at this guy
lots of options here for magnus not
enough pawns left on the ball
and it is magnus thinking for one minute
now
um i'm wondering if
his head is all on the board now i heard
chess players say that
you know and you said it as well the
head start shifting towards dinner
music that's true that is true
but uh just looking at the body language
he looks like he
is in focus mode he knows what he has to
do
and he's going to do it so that's what
uh although he's blinking a lot yeah
so perhaps he's trying to keep himself
awake yeah you can at least hope
for a miracle what happened here with
barr um i think napoleon is taking risks
now to try and win huge ones probably
big risks that's right um we see magnus
carlsen's last move
a very very clever move um if we bring
the board up we can see magnus carson
he's set a trap as well
if black gets greedy it looks like white
has blundered a pawn left this pawn
undefended
we will see a double attack the bishop
will attack the king with check
and take the rook next move meanwhile
magnus he's just going to drop his
bishop into this square he's going to
give check
he's going to try maybe and remove the
opponent's bishop once this bishop
disappears
white's pawn is going to run to the end
and make a new queen so
very clever by magnus carson maybe he's
actually winning right now
yeah um he can even drop his rook with
that
after that bishop check he can drop his
rook all the way up and try and attack
the
bishop that way so yeah well less than
two minutes
on the clock as he is still trying so
hard to push
for a win or even push magnus to do a
blunder
i guess he is very fast losing hope here
now
yeah that's right i think actually it's
time to just
well i don't know if he can take a draw
anymore as black but yeah that's right i
think
actually it's time to just well i don't
know if he can take a draw anymore as
black but it is time to just say okay
you played well magnus
yeah quite get you today and you see it
in his face
he looks completely dejected this he
knows what's going to happen next
that's right and black just retraces
from one square
he shook his head and he left the room
and uh
yeah the game has ended in a draw the
game has ended in a draw jana pognyacci
is
leaving the skilling open he's leaving
the room and we have the two
finalists ready it is world champion
magnus carlson and he will face wesley
so the american
in the skilling open final okay
yay we have the finalists ready yeah
and they're actually the ones who are
the two leaders so it was actually
magnus carlsen and wesley
so they both retained their lead they
did
wow and okay if we think back um
uh six seven days david when we started
the skilling open we had
16 players are you surprised with who we
have in the final finals magnus carlsen
and we now know the final will consist
of magnus carlsen
and wesley so norway against the us
and who will be the winner well we will
know in two days because
the final ivanka is played just like the
quarterfinals and the semi-finals
which means which means that we're gonna
see some fast action chess and it'll be
each match consists of four rapid games
and there'll be two
matches so and if things are tight it's
going to go to tie breaks and i can't
wait
i know so uh important first day we know
that now
uh david who do you think will start out
strong as tomorrow
oh it's so hard to call magnus carlson a
bit of a slow starter but wesley so as
well he's
maybe less experienced in these big
finals when huge money's on the line
maybe he'll take a couple of draws at
the beginning just to warm up into the
match if that happens i think magnus
will win the first day
magnus carlsen versus wesley so it is
the final
in the skilling open we are back
tomorrow
starting out with the final in the the
first final in the champions chess store
it is the final in the skilling open
world champion magnus carlson against
wesley so all right we're going to have
some fun in the studio tomorrow as well
no doubt about it
we really appreciate you've been
appreciate you've been with us
tonight and then we hope to see you
again tomorrow for the skilling open
finals bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you